Click on the spider to enter the game.
Enter the game.
Oh my gosh.
Yes,
we are in glasses mode today.
Because we are having to see with our...
Eyes!
I didn't mean the dramatic pause there, sorry.
I was...
I was checking something on my mic.
Hello!
Hello, hello, welcome in.
I'm quiet?
Am I actually?
Audio is good?
One guide?
Oh, ok.
What the heck?
Why did you say that?
This game might be too spooky for me.
Look at the freaky ghost at the bottom right.
Is my interface ok?
I don't know.
I think so.
I was worried because...
Actually, I thought I sounded quiet because I was like...
Earlier, but...
Yeah.
I got good news from my doctors at Duke University.
Wait, really?
Is that real?
Nerve blockers will help the chronic pain.
Let's go!
Oh my gosh, let's go Brandon!
I hope it all works out.
Good luck, good luck.
One thing I want to say before I begin begin...
So,
I had a lot of trouble getting this game to work in OBS.
It scared me.
Ok, hold on.
Gosh.
And enter your name.
I had a lot of trouble getting this to work.
It's so funny because...
Basically, the one place you can play this is this service called Big Fish Games or whatever.
So I bought it from there.
I tested it earlier and I was like, oh, cool.
It works.
We're all good.
And then, an hour before stream, I tried to set everything up in OBS and everything.
And the game would not capture for whatever reason.
I was like, oh no, what's happening?
So I troubleshooted for like an hour.
I looked even online and there's like an old Reddit post from like three years ago.
That's like, hi, I'm trying to stream I Spy Spooky Mansion from Big Fish Games, but it's not window capturing.
What do I do?
So they were literally me.
Window capture did not work for everybody curious.
It was not window capture.
So that's why I am telling you guys I am doing the thing you are not supposed to do as a VTuber.
And I am desktop capturing.
If I accidentally click onto... And if I click out of the game, it goes black screen.
So sorry if I miss like something.
I can't click out of the game.
And if I accidentally click out or accidentally show my desktop, I already checked.
There's nothing bad.
I exited out of anything that would be spoilers.
So yeah, nothing.
We're all good.
Hide the bookmark bar.
I don't even have anything bad in my bookmarks.
I feel it's just like here's backgrounds that VTubers can use.
I feel that if my desktop were to be leaked, it would be so disappointed by how boring it truly is.
So don't worry about it.
Mint can't see this.
Yes I can.
I am just saying if I have to like scroll.
You know, say someone said something in chat.
I missed it.
It might be difficult.
Or if I have to adjust something.
Hopefully I am not too big.
You know what, I am going to put my arms down.
Just so we can have more of the screen for you guys to see as well.
My wallpaper is not snake right now.
Oh my gosh you guys.
Actually my wallpapers...
I have one blue archive wallpaper and one like Mt.
Fuji wallpaper.
Okay?
Gosh.
It's like... I told you.
It's like so normal.
Okay?
It's because my whole desktop area is very aesthetic.
And Metal Gear does not fit in my aesthetics.
Thanks for the 5k third.
A spy and Minty ghost made.
But yeah, I have this earlier.
Oh no, no, no.
Minto.
Oh you can see my cat.
Oh gosh.
Desktop.
I feel so exposed right now with the desktop audio.
Or audio.
Desktop capture.
I feel really scared right now.
This is... Every time I turn caps lock on, it does this.
And you can only turn it off.
You can't lower the opacity.
You see this?
Like, it's completely opaque.
Like, this is so annoying.
I hate this.
It comes with the Logitech... Whatever, whatever.
Minto looks extra cute today.
Yeah, it's a Logitech thing.
I wish you could at least, like, make it.
Because sometimes I'll be typing something and I accidentally...
Or like, I'll be doing something and I accidentally hit caps lock.
And you can turn it off, but I can't see the caps lock light on.
I'm too short, so...
I have to... This helps me know if it's on or off or not.
I can't see it on my keyboard.
The little light.
It's hidden by the keys.
I have to, like...
I have to, like, extend myself.
So...
I stopped using Logitech and mine still shows that?
Oh, that's the worst.
My chair is as high as it goes, so...
Anyway...
Anyway, I wonder if maybe I could lower my desk.
No, I still can't see it.
OK.
Are you guys ready to go into the game?
Let me turn down the audio just a little.
Hold on, I didn't have time to adjust it.
That should be good.
Let's go!
Minto!
No!
Let me restart!
No, you guys have to see the beginning!
Hold on.
Oh, shoot!
OK.
I turned off... Oh, I only clicked out of the game.
OK, I'm gonna exit out of the game real quick.
Yes.
We have to start over again.
We have to make a new save.
It's fine.
OK, once it starts up...
Display...
Here.
OK.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
Display...
This...
No!
Oh, shoot!
Hold on.
No!
Oh, no!
Give me a second!
I have to restart!
Click on the spider to enter the game.
If you saw...
No!
I can't see the YouTube now!
Oh my gosh, this is a disaster.
No!
I hate this!
I can't get it so that I can see...
OK, I'm gonna have to put it like...
No!
OK.
I fixed it, I think.
Oh my god.
Sorry, it's all happening behind the scenes.
So basically...
Essentially...
If I click...
If I click on YouTube...
To be able to read the chat...
You guys would see...
My...
My screen.
You would see my window.
Not that there's anything bad.
But I don't wanna be exposed!
And so I couldn't read it.
Because OBS was covering it.
Because I usually have the chat overlapping on top of OBS.
But I couldn't switch screens because I had to turn on the desktop capture.
Anyway, we're fine.
We need to commission Minto a technical difficulty screen.
No!
That's not even...
That wouldn't even have helped!
That wouldn't even have helped.
Because I had to have done everything before stream.
Ok, whatever.
Minto...
Binto...
No.
What should we do?
What name should we do?
Minky!
Minky...
So true.
See?
Minky...
This is the part that you had to see.
It's very important.
That's him talking I think.
Yay!
We made it inside.
The way you came in.
There's a puzzle for you.
Wait one second.
Hold on.
Ok.
So here...
We have to go find the puzzle pieces.
This puzzle is a secret message which tells you how to get out of the house.
But the pieces aren't here yet.
To earn puzzle pieces you have to go solve the I Spy riddles and play the games that I've hidden in this house.
Then come back here and put your pieces in place.
Pieces in place.
Wait.
Come back here and put your pieces in place.
I'm stupid.
Why did you say that?
Wait.
And she's like...
Dummy, dumb, dum-dum.
That's exactly what I told you.
Let's go do some puzzles!
Where do we want to go?
We can go in here.
It's a little blocked.
Hopefully I'm not blocking too much of it.
Check the umbrella rack.
I don't think there is anything in there.
There is nothing there.
I grew up with these games.
Look at the rat!
And the cat!
And the bat!
Let's...
Let's go to this room first.
Moose.
Four!
There is a number four here.
Let's do the fireplace.
Oh my god guys.
Four!
Spooky.
F
A dangling spider and an old clipper ship.
That's not a riddle.
F Ok, wait.
So...
I wonder how fast we can speedrun this you guys.
F I An F in a frame.
Oh yeah.
An I.
I forgot they all do this.
Ok, speedrun.
A match.
One match.
Two matches.
Two!
Just looked it.
The VA did a bunch of Pokemon voices.
No way.
A candle flame.
I remember this being like...
Ok, this must be the first...
A dangling spider.
I remember this being so much more difficult when I was a kid.
I was like, oh guys, we're going to be going for like some crazy I Spy adventures.
You know, like we're going to be...
Look at this paperclip.
It's ginormous.
These get more difficult, right?
A paperclip.
What's a clipper ship?
This?
An old clipper ship.
Oh my gosh.
What does it mean by trunk?
Like this?
A trunk.
Ok.
Let's see.
We need a one duck.
One duck.
These sound effects are killing me.
Where is the second duck?
Where are the other ducks?
Why are they hidden?
Did the number mean anything?
Nothing?
Not at all?
Realistic duck.
Oh you're so right.
We need a bone.
Oh I see the bone.
A bone.
I got a bone to pick with you.
Oh I see the duck.
Three ducks.
Oh my God!
Thank you.
I was going to take it but sure, whatever.
We did it guys.
We're so good at this one.
Wait.
We were so good at this one.
Good job everybody.
We're going to speed run this for real.
Mystery bins.
Watch for the hint and figure out how these objects match.
Then empty the bins by clicking on the matching pairs.
Be careful.
Here's your hint.
Oh.
I love being smarter than a first or fifth grader.
Oh my gosh!
It's the best time!
Oh shoot.
Oh my gosh!
It's timed you guys.
It's timed.
What the hell?
Oh my God!
New record!
I'm so good at this.
You guys, we might be speed running this game.
Stop!
Wait, what?
What do these have in common?
I'm sorry.
Why are you sorry Barry?
What did you do?
Oh it's color.
I see it.
Oh my God.
No!
The game is throwing me!
Hey, we had this one before.
That's like totally cheating.
My brain worked too fast!
No!
OK.
Redemption.
Two seconds!
A new record.
I don't think anybody can get faster than that.
Right?
OK.
Oh my gosh.
This one is so difficult.
They are so far away.
They are too far.
I don't think I can do it.
What if we had a touch screen?
If only.
Oh shoot!
This one wasn't meant to be.
Oh!
This one is so good!
OK.
I think one of Featman69's ancestors possessed me.
It will happen again.
No!
That one was so good though!
Almost!
You guys, I don't know if you can get any faster.
I don't know if you can get any faster than two seconds.
It's tough to get a one second record.
I want to put myself on the board.
The game is kind of loud.
What else do you guys think?
A little loud?
I think the music might be a little loud.
Like when it goes boop, boop, boop.
This house is bizarre.
Hi Minky!
K!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear KV.
Happy birthday!
Alright, let's do more finder seeds.
I spy a wishbone, a pinecone, howl, a space for a tooth, a moon, an owl, a face in the sky, a duck safety pin, a fly, a frog, and a face with a grin.
Wait, can I press him?
Pressing skeleman doesn't do anything.
So sad.
OK.
Wait, there is hints even.
We don't need hints.
We are too good for this game.
Look there is another 4 here.
What is this 4?
Duck safety pin.
Wishbone.
Is this a wishbone?
No, this is a horseshoe.
This is a wishbone.
A wishbone.
I see it!
Howl!
Why did he say it like that?
OK, that one was way loud.
A pinecone.
Pinecone.
Pinecone!
A pinecone.
A pinecone on the window.
I see it.
I got it!
A space for a tooth.
I'm blocking this one a little bit.
A half moon.
This one?
It's more like a... That's not a half moon.
That's like a crescent moon.
Why are there so many ducks?
I don't know.
They are obsessed with you, ducky.
That's definitely a crescent moon.
This game is not good for the children.
An owl.
Look at the heart on the little frog.
That's so cute.
A frog.
A fly.
This is the biggest fly ever.
If this thing were in my room...
Oh my god!
This bat is out to kill.
Holy moly!
Oh there's the owl.
An owl.
Why do all the other animals get their...
All the other animals get their own sounds, but the owl is doing a little jig.
Why?
Ew!
The face in the sky is disturbing!
The name Spooky Mansion is living up to its name.
You guys, I didn't own any other iSpy games.
I only cared about this one because it's a spooky mansion when I was a kid.
Just like I mentioned it in Prey Chat when I was trying to solve the OBS issues.
But my other idea for tonight was Freddy Fish 2 The Haunted Schoolhouse.
Because that also was the only Freddy Fish game that I had when I was a kid.
Because it was a haunted schoolhouse.
So I never cared about anything that wasn't having to do with spooky and scary, even as a kid.
Kinoko!
Welcome to membership!
Arigato!
Thank you, thank you.
I have always been obsessed with the spooky and the scary.
Oh!
We just killed that thing.
A face with a grin?
This guy?
We got him!
I've always been a ghost, you guys.
Well, I mean...
Sorry, you can't see him, but little skelly man is on the right.
I am good at this game.
Thank you!
Yeah, I've been dead since I've been dead.
So ever since I was... Ever since I died I've always loved spooky, you know?
Let's go into this creepy...
Ghost!
It's like a ghost.
What a warning sign.
Look at him.
He's so official.
He's ready for official I spy scientific business.
Ghost in bottom right.
Two hooks.
What do they classify it with?
Is this a hook?
No.
Two hooks.
You see them?
The hooks.
Oh there is one.
Oh there is two.
I see them.
Two hooks.
A ghost.
I'm trying to click on me, but it's not working.
I'm too fast.
You can't.
You can't click on me.
I'm too fast.
Yeah baby!
You can't click on me!
I'm dizzy now.
OK, let's pick a ghost.
Number...we can't pick the spookiest number.
They don't allow...
Six numbers in line.
Oh we have to do that.
OK number four.
Six numbers in line.
No, no.
I'm picking the ghost.
Six numbers in line.
I hate this game.
I don't even know that was a thing.
Look there is a foot in the wall.
A bug in a jar.
What is the bug made out of?
What the hell?
Why did it make such a horrible sound?
One goggle.
One pair of goggles.
Two pairs of goggles.
Never again please.
I hope not.
This is hot.
I'm blocking it with my head.
A warning sign.
I'm a first time viewer.
First time chatter.
Sorry to intrude but can you please tell my son Cory to get back to his studies.
Cory!
Cory, Cory, Cory.
What the heck are you doing?
Stop watching Vtubers and get back to your studies Cory!
You've been busted.
Busted by the ghost which I usually am getting busted instead.
Cory get back to your studies.
Get out of here Cory.
Cory leave.
Leave this place.
A bone that's stone.
I love all these sound effects.
Why can't I pick the ghost?
So sad.
Wooden handle...
Oh this one.
A star.
Oh here.
It's behind chat.
A star.
How do I pick the ghost?
Is this?
Ghost.
What's going on?
Hey...
Sorry to intrude but can you tell my dad Albert to mind his own business.
Albert!
Albert, Albert, Albert.
Mr. Albert, mind your own beeswax.
Your son, he's doing his best.
You know what?
He needs time to relax and watch VTubers in between his studies.
He needs time to be a kid.
Okay?
But out Albert.
Leave Cory to his business.
Thank you.
We're causing a family rift here.
On stream.
Let's do this one.
We'll just like conquer the fold.
I spy your name.
A thumb.
A four.
Two keys with three holes.
A closed door.
A ladybug.
The number nine twice.
A peanut.
A penny.
And a pair of dice.
Albert, I saw you respond.
Like a dog?
I spy your name.
That's me!
A thumb.
A four.
It's just like the end of MGS2.
Two Minky.
That's me you guys!
Oh my gosh.
Two keys with three holes.
Sorry, I should have finished reading it.
One hole?
How does it know my name?
Two keys with three holes.
Two keys with three holes baby.
Thank you, thank you, thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
At this point we need either a Minky emote or something.
At least a matching kit.
I don't have any more emote slots.
But I was thinking maybe...
So Gringus, yes, I love this game too.
I was thinking of maybe updating events.
I don't want to update some of my 1.0 ones though.
Because like, they're so nostalgic to me.
But I was like maybe I should update my emotes to be...
To update...
Like, you know, I don't know.
I don't know.
Raymac, thanks for the 10 gifted!
But I have no more emote slots, so...
I don't know yet.
I know, I don't know yet what I want to do.
Please never get rid of the one I drew all those years ago.
A closed door.
Oh.
A ladybug.
That's Barry!
Is that what you were apologizing for?
You're going to get eaten if you go close to that spider.
The number 9 twice.
OK, I'm blocking this one but it's a pencil.
Can you kind of see it?
The number 9 once.
And number 9...
Number 9... Oh here.
Boba isn't on brand anymore.
As on brand anymore.
That's true.
That is true.
It is kind of...
And I have a sippy, don't I?
Like, don't I have a sippy emote?
So maybe we don't need the boba.
True, true, true, true.
That's a 6.
No!
You could see!
It's sideways.
Never change this emote.
I love it so much.
A peanut.
Here.
I'm laughing.
Journal reference?
Yeah.
And a pair of dice.
I see one.
I'm blocking it.
You can see it popping behind me.
And two dice.
A pair of dice.
We are so good at this game!
Oh my god.
My games are tricky.
I'm sure you can tell.
Here's puzzle piece 5.
You're doing quite well.
Thank you.
My games are... Oh his legs were here the whole time.
Nice.
Alright, let's go into this room now.
Oh there's more.
Ok, ok.
We'll start from the left side.
The clock.
Praise the sun!
Upside down 1.
A hand on the wall.
The rhyme for a 3.
A backwards number.
This was the scariest game for me in second grade.
I was so scared of the skeleton and thought the goal was to kill it.
I would shake and force it to turn off my computer.
That's so silly.
Oh my gosh.
I love that though.
I spy Minky.
Me?
Let's see.
I spy a rhyme.
I see a rhyme up here.
Rhyme.
Time talks.
Tick tock!
Oh my gosh.
A hand to the sun.
This guy is actually demonic.
Like this one?
A hand to the sun.
Praise the sun!
Oh it's a clock hand.
Three horns?
One horn.
What?
That's so cheating.
Two horns.
That feels like it's cheating.
They are right on the same guy.
Three horns.
Minky!
Oh there's the third horn.
Three horns.
Minky!
The spider!
Oh my gosh.
They were gonna put me down.
They were
gonna...
That's some pig.
That's some Minky.
A skate.
I see it.
This game is like... sometimes that one was nice, but sometimes it's like anti-ASMR.
You know if they remade this nowadays, all the sounds would be like super...
super satisfying.
You know what I mean?
An upside down one.
Oh I see it!
A hand on the wall.
I see it.
Eww!
Who is tickling that guy?
A rhyme for a three?
Rhyme for a three?
What does that mean?
A backwards number?
Rhyme for a three.
Oh!
B?
B!
The rhyme for a three.
A crack.
Is it this thing?
I'm glad... I'm glad there's no Magic the Gathering players here.
And a key.
A key.
Oh
with his foot even!
Skelly is kind of freaky.
I should re-dub this game.
Dinner is served everybody!
Oh my god!
Look at how many lizards there are!
A fork face.
Eww this thing.
Oh my gosh Skelly really just jump scared me there.
A tongue?
Where would a tongue be?
Oh here it is!
Oh my gosh!
We're going to touch the snake's tongue.
A tongue.
Two nails.
I'm blocking the second nail.
Sorry guys.
Two nails.
A face on a coin.
Mr. Lincoln.
I convinced myself and another girl at my daycare that the iSpy books had some kind of cryptic ARG in the meanings.
Sounds like something I would have done.
Three lizard tails.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, but this guy.
Can we tickle him out?
Oh here's the third lizard!
I'm literally sorting magic cards right now.
What are you going to do Eternity?
Two lizard tails.
Three lizard tails.
A spitter.
A spider.
A screw.
Oh that's a nail.
Is this a screw?
No that's a bolt.
A screw.
A screw?
You saw it?
A screw.
It's a screw.
Screw.
A screw.
I'm blocking it but there is an eyeball on the table.
Freaky.
Two sticks for a drum.
Bless you.
A spoonful of bugs.
Eww.
Eww Matara-Kan go away.
A yum.
There is one yum here.
I'm kind of blocking it.
Sorry.
I can't believe Matara is going to be in my house.
Yum.
Where is a screw?
Screw.
A screw.
Is this a screw?
The fork yum is clever.
It's cute right?
You saw that.
I got confused.
I was thinking of the screwdriver instead of the screw screw.
And go.
Thanks for the super chat.
Thank you.
The fork does not look like a face to me.
This one?
Ok here.
It's the eyes here.
And then this is a big old nose.
And then he's got a big creepy smile.
He looks like an uncle.
He looks like a big water drop.
But his eyes, eye, eye, nose, smile.
Yeah, you see it now?
You see it now?
Like a reflection.
Is that me?
Are you saying I got a big nose?
Are you saying I have a big nose now?
Look at that dog.
I think this is the last one in here.
Oh what is this?
The kitchen?
Oh my god that cat is so cute.
Ew!
See you.
I see you.
I didn't know that there were Metal Gear references in this game.
Wow!
Ice Spice?
I heard it too.
Ice Spice.
I heard that too.
I was like...
I have you.
Spice.
A knife.
What do you have?
Where is the knife?
Knife.
Oh there it is.
No!
A four.
A four, four, four, four, four.
Oh this is the handrail, right?
What's a rebus door?
This?
Oh god.
Stop!
Can I see you pee?
No!
I come!
A rebus door.
What the hell is that?
A bug?
A spoon in a bowl?
Oh I forgot the four.
Where is the four at?
There is the bug in the spoon.
Oh my god!
They added it to the recipe.
Shape of a moon.
Oh I see the four.
I see it.
Guys, dinner is almost ready.
A scale.
Oh down here?
This game is like missing music, but like...
It has the music when you find stuff, but like...
It's missing actual music.
Like just some BGM, you know?
A shell.
Do you guys see the shell anywhere?
I wish the cat was a thing.
Oh I'm blocking it, but there is a hotdog in it.
Ok, hold on.
Oh wait, I can't click out.
No!
Oh eggshell, you guys are so smart.
I wish I could show you the hotdog.
Here, I'll print screen it.
And I'll send it to you guys later.
Who decided on that sound?
Oh it was terrible.
They need to oil the skilly man.
It sounds so bad.
Wiener pick.
No!
Corey has escaped.
What is going on?
Who haunts this mansion anyway?
Let's do this one.
It sounds insane.
Oh no, it's this again.
Ready, set, go!
I was taking a drink.
Oh no, I missed the butterfly.
Oh my god it's timed also.
This is timed also.
How am I supposed to get the world record if you are not giving me anything that I need?
No, that's a duck.
Yes!
Not the world record though.
Alright, this is RNG run.
I hate this!
Bug.
That's a fish.
That's a duck.
Bug.
Hi Barry.
Oh they are going fast.
I did it!
Oh my god.
Shadows
Please give me what I need.
My world record please!
Hot dog!
My world record!
Please!
Thank
you.
Thank you Skelly-Man.
I spy the cutest baby sister that Shimiko could ever ask for.
My PB though.
My PB.
Musical.
Oh wait.
It's not giving me anything.
That counts.
You guys, I don't know if I can get faster than 16.
Come on!
I don't think I can get faster than 16.
PB.
Personal best.
Fish.
Fish!
Gone fishing boys.
We are going fishing.
Fish!
Duck doesn't count right?
Which ones are still in the...
That's a dog!
Fish!
I give up.
I think...oh hand.
I think 16 might be the best I can get in this game.
They don't give me anything.
Oh.
Oh baby.
Baby hand.
Oh severed hand.
That's a little morbid.
It's a little scary.
How did they get that reference image?
Come on!
I think 16 is our best.
Alright.
OK last try.
Oh my god it's so cute.
Anything counts.
As long as it's an animal.
Come on!
Yes!
15 seconds baby!
OK we beat it.
Your Karaokes are great for long road trip car rides.
I got pulled over listening to what?
Cop and I vibe to Heaven's Divide and he let me go?
What?
Did that really happen?
No way!
This room is so spoo...what's this?
Oh my god this is so fun!
Oh my god this one is so cool!
I spy a spitter.
Spitter, spitter, spitter.
That's a fly.
I'm so sorry guys.
I wish I could make myself smaller.
Any minkies around?
Look there is a fish.
Wow these are so cool!
And then this guy over here.
I was the burglary hiding in the car.
Look at this ghost!
Looks just like me.
Oh gosh you can see the skelly face.
A spider.
Oh I see the feather.
Oh I see the lightning bolt.
These ones are not so direct you know.
A face made of spots.
I got it.
An old graveyard.
An old gravestone.
Oh I see the spider.
It's just an actual spider.
A spider.
A bone.
Oh that was easy.
Ok but this one actually kind of looks like me.
Ok this is my eye.
And then this is me winking.
And then this is my tooth.
Do you guys see it?
Do you guys see this one?
It actually looks like me.
And I'm smiling and then this is my fang.
Yeah?
A water drop.
Is this it?
Swamp.
Stay out of my... Swamp.
Don't care.
Hey don't care.
Swamp.
Three nails.
Here's one.
One nail.
Two nails.
Two yellow tails.
There's one.
I don't know if that's a tail.
One yellow tail.
It's like a yellow...
butt.
What would the other yellow tail be?
A swamp.
Do you guys see a swamp?
Scream.
Swamp.
This is freaky.
You see it?
Swamp.
What am I missing?
I need one more nail.
Oh I see it.
That one was tricky.
That one was really well hidden.
Now one more yellow tail.
This one maybe.
Two yellow tails.
Thank you.
That one was fun.
What else is in here?
Oh just these two?
I know that if this game was remade too.
Like for now times.
It would be like you would click on something.
Like his head would spin and she would like sneeze.
This guy would crawl.
You know what I mean?
A backwards book.
A rat eye that's red.
A T back in place.
My head is covering the rat's eye.
Sorry.
He's pointing at me!
That guy is pointing at me!
What do you want?
I'm scared.
Let's get the rat.
A rat eye that's red.
You can kinda see it when I do.
You know?
He sees me!
I don't want this kind of attraction.
I mean attention.
I'm so excited.
I can finally ask for this.
My birthday is this Thursday.
Can I get a happy birthday?
Really busy this week preparing for my idol debut and graduation.
Oh my god, Ashes.
Good thing you asked today because Thursday I won't be streaming.
So yeah, of course!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Ashes.
Good luck with your idol debut graduation!
Alrighty, a ladder.
A ladder.
This is so sad, the little waxy mouse head.
A waxy mouse head.
Do you ever have trouble finding a trustworthy babysitter for Butaro and Paz when you travel?
No, because I have my roommate.
My roommate doesn't mind, so it's all good.
Rockero, welcome back for 4 months!
Why are you pointing at me?
Do the glasses give you a buff to your intelligence or to your...
What's C-H-R?
C-H-R.
Oh, charisma!
Definitely my intelligence.
A backwards book.
This one?
Oh, that's fun.
A T back in place.
The seventh ghost.
The wiener's cup.
What the hell?
A wiener's cup.
A gyroscope.
I see this T, but a T back in place.
Is this a T?
No.
Oh, T!
Where does it go?
Here!
A T back in place.
And a bug crawling up.
A bug crawling up.
That's Doki's cup.
Thank you!
Piece 11 is what you have won.
11?
You'll get out of the house when the message is done.
When the message is done.
Skeet?
S-K-E-E-T
I like this other second Metal Gear reference.
Skeet on study.
I think we did everything in this room.
This looks like it would be one, but I guess not.
So now we get out of the study and we go into the bedroom.
Wait, no, the attic.
We'll save the attic for last.
It's probably the spookiest.
Oh, there's three in here.
I wish I could move over some more.
I'm so sorry guys.
Let's go to the bathroom.
I'm assuming this is the bathroom.
Oh my god, we're intruding!
Get a grip!
And a candle flame.
A bar of soap.
A toothbrush.
This one is pretty well hidden.
That one is pretty well hidden.
Toothbrush.
Look at... I actually... I want... This is the nicest... This is such a nice bathroom.
The wallpaper is nice.
The little piggy and polar bears are good.
A trap.
You got a little skelly man taking a bath.
Look at the water is clean and everything.
This place... This place has been used.
A silver handle.
Silver handle.
One jack.
Two jacks.
Someone wrote my name in the smoke!
In the steam!
Oh my god.
This is terrifying.
This game is so scary you guys.
A nine.
It's a six now.
A square picture frame.
This is... Oh.
Which one is square enough?
This one is square?
This one is... No, no.
A toothbrush.
This one?
This one.
Square picture frame.
A square picture frame.
A grip on a pole.
What does that mean?
A brown bottle cap.
And a candle flame.
A candle flame is easy.
A candle flame.
Minky in da house.
I am haunting this place.
Oh there is the bottle cap!
Oh my gosh!
A brown bottle cap.
A silver handle and a grip on a pole.
Is this the pole?
No.
Look at this guy's face in the wall.
It's freaky.
It's pretty freaky.
A grip on a pole.
Oh wait!
There is the...
Lampy!
Thanks for the gifted!
A pole.
A grip on a pole.
Oh like this.
The grip... OK.
I was thinking like gripping a pole.
So I was thinking like a hand...
Like a hand gripping the pole.
You know what I mean?
Yeah, yeah.
How many pieces have you gotten from me?
12!
Here is a hint.
It's 15 minus 3.
I love the ducky has like super anime eyes.
I don't know if you can tell but they are like very bright and full of life.
Let's go into their closet.
I spy a saddle, crossed legs, a rickety chair, a handshake, a handstand, four braids of hair, a boy in a frame, a girl in a hoop, a pair of blue jeans, and a yo-yo loop.
Scratch that.
Answered my own question.
Huh?
Like...
Oh my god!
Oh god!
We finally got to...
We got to the haunted part of the...
We got to the spooky mansion part of the...
Snake?
Oh yeah.
I mean...
Oh my gosh this one is terrifying.
I spy a saddle.
A saddle.
He is so polite though.
Look at him.
Crossed legs!
Oh my god!
A rickety chair?
Help her!
The chair is about to take off.
It's too rickety.
A boy in a frame?
OK.
I'm glad the boy didn't move.
I do not understand.
Please describe in detail a hand gripping a pole please.
Stop!
Stop it.
I'm new to the VTuber scene but I love W3D.
Doki and you will be supporting.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
I really appreciate it.
And thanks for the super chat!
A saddle.
A saddle, saddle, saddle.
Saddle, yaddle, yaddle, yaddle.
Four braids of hair.
Oh one?
Or two?
Two braids of hair.
Four braids of hair.
Can you imagine this game but with...instead of like the things moving the way they do now, it's like live 2D.
A handstand.
A handshake.
A yo-yo.
A yo-yo loop.
Did you guys know that I used to do like... I wouldn't say professional yo-yoing but like...
I did like...
Like real intense yo-yoing.
Like I would do the walk the dog.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Things like that.
Like I bought... I actually had like professional grade yo-yos and stuff like that.
I was super into yo-yoing for like a little bit of time.
No, I didn't ever do it competitively.
Like I had... Me and like one other friend, we got really into yo-yoing together.
And so after school, we would do the yo-yo stuff together and I like had... I had like...
What's it called?
Like videos on yo-yoing and...
I don't remember how... Why I got into it though.
I don't remember why.
But I remember I really loved my yo-yo because it was...
It was a glow-in-the-dark yo-yo.
So it was like kind of ectoplasm colored-ish.
Like it was like a creamy green.
Like a cream... Well, you know like how glow-in-the-dark stuff is.
How it's like kind of not quite white.
It looks like snot.
I love that thing.
Oh my gosh, I love that thing.
A girl in a hoop?
Oh.
Look at her go!
A pair of blue jeans!
Oh my gosh.
A saddle.
It's the only thing I can't find.
Yo-yo stream win?
I don't know if I could still do it.
Glasses and yo-yo skills bring out the geek sexy.
Stop!
I don't know what that means.
All us millennials are really into yo-yoing.
Did you ever do Devil Sticks or Fushigi Bomb?
No.
Only yo-yo.
Fuzzy Snake?
No.
Only yo-yo.
Okay, but there is a difference between being into yo-yoing and then like actually doing like...
You know, like someone could yo-yo, but then someone...
You know, it's different.
It's a different thing.
I didn't just have a normal yo-yo.
I had a really expensive yo-yo.
I had to save up so much for it.
Minky!
The advanced yo-yo.
Yeah!
A full moon!
Minky!
Oh my gosh, this is my book!
I'm a published author.
What the moon brought.
Is this Yuri?
What is this?
What?
It's my book.
I'm a published author.
Footprints.
It says footprints.
Oh here.
Footprints.
Three bows.
One...
Two...
Two bows.
Oh my gosh, he's all tucked away.
That's so cute.
Little Skelly.
You're truly the platonic ideal of an otaku.
Shut up.
You know, actually I take that as a compliment.
Oh three.
Wow, that one is hidden.
That one is so good.
It's the third bow.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, the third bow is so sneaky.
That's good.
A face with no eyes.
A clock face.
A foot with no toes.
Is this an old cow?
I guess he kind of has toes.
A foot with no toes.
Nose of a mouse.
Oh my gosh, it's so cute.
A porcelain head.
Sorry I'm blocking her, but it's for your own safety honestly.
An eye back in place.
A needle.
Does this count?
No.
A needle.
Oh, a foot with no toes.
Oh my gosh, a foot with no toes.
American joke.
Needle.
A needle.
And thread.
Thread.
Oh here.
One Piece?
The One Piece is real!
Wait, no way.
Oh my gosh, boobs.
Wait, I want to go see.
Oh, maybe we should have been doing this the whole time.
This one?
There are too many pieces.
It's hard to see.
Here?
I can't see it.
Oh there?
Let's do this one.
Oh my gosh, guys.
You guys!
And this one.
Time to get out.
Are you ready now?
I wrote this message to show you how.
Oh, go to the room with a spider on the ceiling to find a door I've been concealing.
Find three books on a... shit?
Shelf?
Sorry, I went S-H-T.
With a white man.
Pull them in this order.
Blue, green, then red.
Skeleton.
Elf on the Shelf.
Real.
I thought the same thing.
Oh my gosh, this is so scary!
Kazoo!
I see the monster face.
A monster face.
Let's buy a skate.
A skate.
Skate.
Oh there is a saw.
A saw.
Boo in the bottom right.
Boo!
We had a professional yo-yoer come to our school once.
I think it was the same year we had an ex-wrestler tell us bullying was bad before he ripped a phone book in half and bent a metal back over his knee.
What?
No way.
We had the people from... Oh my gosh, what was it called?
That TV show.
Fear Factor.
They came to my school.
The Fear Factor people.
And I ate bugs.
They were like cute ones to eat bugs.
And I said...
It was so awesome.
I never had a wrestler though.
Man!
Black picture frame.
Let's go.
Oh here.
A black picture frame.
Yeah, I willingly did that.
Oh kazoo!
Oh a zoo.
I see the skate also.
A skate.
Who?
Who is... Joe?
Is that a guy from Fear Factor?
What if Minto was called Pinto?
She was the first ever BeanTuber.
Pinto Bean.
Joe Mama!
No!
Oh my
go...
Boo.
Got him.
A ball for a game.
It's a baseball.
A bat.
Like a baseball bat or a bat bat?
Oh!
A bat bat.
To be fair, the guy from Fear Factor is Joe Rogan.
Oh, I don't know who came.
I don't remember at all.
I just remember them asking me to eat bugs.
I don't know.
Is he like a famous guy then that asked me to eat the bugs?
I have no idea.
Was he bald?
I don't know.
I remember one lady and one guy.
So I don't really remember.
I don't know.
He's pretty famous.
Yeah, but beware Matara.
I'll eat your head off.
I'll eat you just like... Isn't that what they do when they are mating?
Oh a wooden chair.
Oh my gosh.
Snakey.
A wooden chair.
See the cage?
A cage.
Two snakes.
Twin snakes.
Oh my gosh that's a fish.
Snakes.
Twin snakes.
Oh one snake!
Corey has burned the house down.
Is everything ok there Albert?
Is everything ok there?
I went and slept at the science museum for school.
I loved things like that.
Yes!
I never did them for school.
But I was in Girl Scouts.
I did those for Girl Scouts.
Does that count as a candle?
No it's a candlestick.
Oh candle is behind me.
A candle.
Alright one more snake.
One more snake.
Do you guys see the second snake?
Snake.
One more snake.
We got this guy.
Look at that cat.
So cute.
Albert?
Max camo index real.
I don't see him.
Two snakes.
Sneaky!
We
get to leave the house.
Here's your last piece.
You're finished.
You're done.
Decode the secret message and this game will be won.
I believe though.
I think I remember from when I was a kid that you can play the game again and there is different puzzles.
If I remember correctly.
Pick up your piece.
It's time to get out.
Are you ready now?
I wrote this message to show you how.
No, you're spoiling it.
I'm supposed to decode it myself.
To find a door I've been concealing.
Find three books on a shelf with a white head.
Oh that's a head.
I thought it was a white man.
Reminds me of when we had a science man come to our school I went to.
I got picked for a turn as a volunteer and we had to do is eat plastic.
Wait, what?
You had to eat... Wait, they made you eat plastic?
D plus Ear Minky.
The shit elf.
They made you eat plastic?
That's so messed up.
Delicious microplastics.
Minky!
Why wouldn't you say this part game?
Ok, wait.
Actually we have to figure this out.
Room with a spider on the ceiling.
And then three books on a... I keep reading.
I keep reading shit elf.
I was that science man.
I just wanted to watch cool kids eat plastic.
Alright guys, remember blue, green, red.
Ganker!
We had a professional yo-yo... Oh wait.
In high school my cousin got caught drinking and driving.
He ended up in a colostomy bag.
So they sent a guy to our school... Wait, what?
They sent a guy to our school to tell us it was bad.
During the climax of his speech it's dead silent.
My cousin's bag goes...
And it killed the speech.
What happened in there?
The bag is filled with poo.
No!
Why did your cousin have to do that because of drunk driving?
Ok, room with a spider on the ceiling.
Find three books on the shit elf.
Does this room have a spider?
No.
This room?
Upstairs.
This room.
Three bookshelves.
I mean three shelves.
What was the order?
There is a lot of red.
Oh I see him!
Blue, green, red?
No way.
I got lucky?
Holy moly.
I got lucky!
Are you telling me to jump out the window?
What the hell?
To do trick, scare, haunt.
That's my to do list.
Are you here?
Also I love this.
Oh my god I love the portrait of him with his mom.
Boo!
I guess I'll jump out the window now.
Good thing I'm a ghost.
Why is it so crackly?
If you dare to come back in, a new adventure will begin.
OK let's do it.
Let's go back in baby!
Look it's different!
There's more.
Could there be another door?
New game plus time.
Different rat.
If you want to get out now, go to the kitchen.
I'll show you how.
The kitchen.
OK the kitchen was in here.
To get out this time, you'll have to make my favorite recipe.
That's fun!
Shrinking soup.
First, fill my kitchen with ingredients by playing I Spy Riddles and games.
OK.
Shrinking soup makes one serving.
All clues completed.
Skeleton meated.
Window yeeted.
I have a ghost question.
Is it possible for the same person to have a ghost and a zombie of themselves at the same time?
Yes.
OK let's go do I Spy Puzzles baby!
Back to the clock!
Mickey!
Off the clock.
OK guys.
All right we got this.
I wish that we could pick Mickey.
OK tick.
I saw it earlier.
Oh here.
We got this so easy now because...
Oh my god!
We've memorized.
We've memorized these maps.
We're geniuses now.
A pen.
A ten!
An apple core.
OK I don't know where that is.
I've been vodging recently but glad I could catch the stream live.
Selfos thank you!
It's my birthday tomorrow.
Let me sing you!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Selfos!
Happy birthday!
An apple core.
Tick tock.
Sticks for six.
I don't know what that means though.
And a teapot.
A teapot.
OK I said we were going to be really fast with this but I think I'm just...
Oh there it is.
A teapot.
What does sticks for six mean?
Oh!
Sticks for six.
Very good everybody.
Aha!
The kitchen game has begun.
I'm giving you ingredient number one.
Oh my gosh!
We got an apple!
An apple-e-ple.
OK awesome.
Two... Do you think he's going to be there on the plate again?
I spot two red bugs.
A dime.
Five flies.
An ear.
I don't have time for you to explain.
A dime.
Red bug one.
One red bug.
Two red bug.
Two red bugs.
Five flies.
OK that's way too many flies.
One fly.
Two flies.
Three flies.
Four flies.
Five flies.
Five flies at dinner.
An ear.
Saw teeth.
One brown eye.
One dark brown eye.
One dark brown... Two dark brown eyes?
What's the other brown eye?
It's not the snake?
No it's green.
What's that?
Oh my gosh I'm covering it.
I'm sorry.
There is an eye on the table.
Three aces.
Two dark brown eyes.
Hey there Minky.
Have you ever heard of Minky Momo?
The toy company that was funding the show pulled out.
So the animators ended the show by having Minky get hit by a truck.
The show literally ends with their funeral.
What?
Hold on.
I'm looking at Minky Momo right now.
Minky Momo.
No way.
I know this show.
I never finish it.
No way.
That's how it ends?
Minky Momo.
Spoilers.
Spoilers to this show that's like... from the 80s.
A pearl from above.
I don't know what above means.
What do you mean by that?
It's just a regular pearl.
An empty plate.
A bone.
No.
An empty plate.
A bone.
A bee.
Look at him wiggle.
And an animal ate?
That's fun.
An animal ate.
He ate.
Thank you for that little lore about...
About the Minky Momo though.
What is that?
Frog legs?
I want to watch it now.
Minky Momo is like famously cursed.
The final episode where she gets hit by the truck aired right before a huge earthquake in Japan.
Minky Momo.
A cat.
What if it said like some grippers.
Wait.
I thought it had five toes for a second.
Two P's.
There is one.
Two.
One P. No.
No.
Say what it is.
It's a P. A second P. Two P's.
No.
Don't say a letter P. Just say P. Two P's.
P. A pair of pink ears.
I think it's this little guy.
Oh my ears.
For the domino I'm blocking it so I'm really sorry.
A footprint.
Oh the grippers.
Oh my god look at those toes.
A cat.
That's not a footprint though.
Oh there is a cat.
So cute.
A set of old gears.
Oh here.
Right behind chat.
Nice guys.
Nice going.
A bottle and a trumpet.
My ears!
A hole.
A hole where the 7th button will go.
The audio in this is not very consistent.
I'm sorry.
We are guarding the metal gears.
It's an egg!
Yeah actually.
What's wrong with it?
It's just an egg.
The other ones were like this one is bugs.
This one is frog legs.
But this one is an egg.
Would you still eat it?
The mysterious and spooky egg.
Oh.
Toopies!
Thanks for the super chat.
I spy my name!
What sound effect do you think my name will give?
I think it will give something kind of like bossa nova.
Your name.
I spy a star.
I spy with my little eye.
Oh no, that's a king.
A jack.
Jack.
I don't see a jack.
Oh wait, is this a jack?
A jack.
Oh, what are these things?
This is a jack?
I think I saw it.
It said it earlier, right?
I think because of the cards I was thinking like a jack card.
Jacks like the game.
I've never played it.
A bent paper clip.
Oh here.
Toy for grand people.
Konami should make a super prequel to MGS.
Should be called Wooden Gear in future Action Snakes.
Trying to thwart cavemen inventing the wheel.
Truly, Metal Gear started...
At the beginning.
I'm blocking the star by the way, sorry.
A star.
Truly, Metal Gear started with the cave people.
A lens with a crack.
Oopsie.
Skelly face.
A skeleton face.
A frog.
A 2.
A 2, 2, 2.
I see a 3.
I see a K.
I see an Ace.
I see a 4, 1, 5.
I see a 9.
I see a 6.
Or a 9.
2.
Do you guys see a 2?
A 2.
Do you guys see it?
The 2.
Do you guys see a 2?
A 2.
Let's do a key and a lock.
Where is that one?
Here.
A key and a lock.
A paper shoe?
What is a paper shoe?
Oh!
A shoe that is actually paper.
Paper shoe.
A 2?
Do you guys see a 2?
Is there a 2 on the pencil?
No, it's a 9.
A 2?
You guys...
I'm not blocking...Oh wait.
It was on the dice.
Oh my gosh.
It was the 2 on the dice.
I was blocking it.
Sorry.
Thank you.
Oh what is that?
Caterpillars.
There is a character in Mobile Suit Gundam Z that has a character named Haman Karn.
Who looks like an older Minky Momo, so me and my friends joke that Minky Momo got isekai in Gundam.
There is a 10 in the bottom right corner.
No, it's a 9.
It's a 9 on the pencil.
Alright, let's go into this room.
We are speedrunning, but not really.
We get to do this again.
Holy moly!
You got...Wait, what?
Oh...
What?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7?
8?
6?
1?
Oh 10 because it's a dime?
Oh my god.
1...12
But watch out, the objects match in a different way this time.
A different way this time.
What do they do?
Okay, this is just similar things.
Oh 6 seconds!
A new record.
Oh no, no, no, no!
Why, what the hell is this one?
2?
Okay, 4...
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11?
3?
2?
Wait, 11?
Wait, this is 11.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12!
I can't count.
5?
Okay, okay.
Alright, the sun is 12.
Yeah, 2 coins is 11.
11...
4...
3...
Oh 2, sorry.
This one is too hard!
A snake!
Ingredient 5 sure is yummy.
Can't wait to have soup in my tummy.
Oh yeah, that snake is yummy.
Look at the way he just cradled him away.
You can keep playing Mystery Bins to find more matches.
Okay, let's see.
Is this...OK, Nickel?
Hammer?
Dog?
Yo-Yo?
Ant?
What the hell is this one?
Oh, Xylophone.
Wait, Hammer?
Lollipop?
Wait, no!
We are speedrunning!
Get me out of here!
It's fine, we don't care anymore.
Wait, it's now a different thing.
It's 7 instead of 4.
Oh, it is a 4.
Am I...?
Guys, I sw...
I don't know what...
I think my eyes actually played...
I saw it as a 7 and then I looked away and then I looked back and it's a 4!
What the heck?
I think my eyes are playing tricks on me.
It's these glasses!
They are not prescription!
I spy Venus.
A dog.
Venus?
A snake.
A wi...
A dog.
Venus.
Oh that's a raccoon.
A dog.
A snail.
A wide open mouth.
Sorry, I'm blocking it a little bit.
A tree on a nail.
I don't know.
That was really weird though.
That was actually so weird.
1, 4?
1, 4.
2, 4.
The glasses give you no tactical advantage.
I know!
2, 4s.
That was actually so weird.
1, bat.
2, bat.
2, bats.
3, bats.
3,
bats.
4, 5 pointed stars.
What?
4 of them?
1, 5 pointed star.
Wait.
4, 5.
Oh, that's 6.
Sorry.
This one?
2?
2, 5 pointed stars.
Oh here's one.
Here's one.
3, 5 pointed stars.
Where's the last one?
You guys see it?
Do you guys see the last one?
Don't tell me.
Let me find it.
But do you see it?
Tell me if you see it.
You see it?
Don't tell me where.
Green Caterpillar.
And then Bike Handlebars.
OK we got that one.
Bike Handlebars.
Green Caterpillar.
What?
What did the Foley artist have to use to create that sound?
I truly wonder.
Also the Skelly's hand, I wish I could show you it right now because it looks mega fucked.
Hunter, thanks for the super chat!
I see the star.
I found it.
4, 5 pointed stars.
Ask Doobie.
Yeah, I know right?
Since you did Foley stuff.
He just gave me some milk.
Alright,
now we have the fireplace.
Two arrows.
One!
One arrow.
Two arrows.
The number 4 and definitely not a 7.
The number 4.
Fresh wood on a fire.
Oh fresh wood.
Fresh wood.
Fresh?
A bat.
I saw it.
I just...oh here.
I'm enjoying your stream so far on my days off.
A bat.
And they are ad free which is a plus.
Oh, sorry.
Do I need to insert an ad?
GamerSupps Code Boomer.
10% off your order.
Right now I'm drinking GamerSupps Black Cherry.
All proceeds, well not all, 10%, wait.
Some proceeds go to Minto.
Code Boomer.
Birthday!
Sorry, it's tomorrow.
OK.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Rudabrand...
Rudabrand...
Happy birthday to you.
Birthday!
Oh yeah, also another ad.
In between ads.
Sorry, since you requested more ads.
Phantom Thief concert.
December 14th.
At the Tabernacle in Atlanta, Georgia.
Tickets are still on sale.
Doobie's a guest.
Oh, it's me and Doki in 3D.
Our first ever 3D concert.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, it's during the same time as a convention.
That's happening there.
But we're not associated with the convention.
It's just a coinkidinkle.
And it is not during the Hololive concert.
We made sure of that while we were planning the dates.
Yes.
A nail that might fall.
No, it fell.
Letter E.
And E.
A nail in the wall.
Halo has a concert too?
Yeah.
So, it's a very packed weekend, I'd say.
Yes, yes, yes.
A cracked door.
A cracked open door.
Guys, this king has no eyes.
Freaky.
Also, a car.
Okay, we gotta lock in, guys.
We gotta get through these.
A car, a car, a car, a car.
Oh my gosh, a moose.
Also, fresh wood on the fire.
But this isn't...
Oh, there's the car!
Oh my gosh, this is cute!
A car.
And an R.
R.
Oh my gosh, there's another snake.
Fresh wood on the fire.
And an R.
Oh, these ones are tripping me up, you guys.
And a cracked open door.
Wait, is this the door?
A cracked open door.
Oh my gosh, I didn't even realize that was a door!
That's crazy.
Oh, here's the wood.
That's cute!
Fresh wood on the fire.
And an R.
Is it the pirate saying R?
No.
There's the R!
These ones were pretty tricky.
My cursor stopped working.
Oh my gosh, Nikki.
Reset your computer.
What is that?
Hot sauce or ketchup?
The cat is so cute.
Beer?
No, skeletons can't.
Streamly reminder that you can buy used offshore oil rigs.
They auction them off.
Stop.
Stop tempting me.
OK, I think we finished downstairs, so...
Hold on, let's go check out the kitchen and see how much ingredients we've got.
Milk?
Hot sauce?
Snake in a jar?
Apple?
Fly?
Froggy legs?
Shrinking soup.
Makes one serving.
Upstairs we go.
That is not milk.
I agree.
Let's do this one first.
Wait.
Oh my god.
They don't even explain.
They are like, you know the rules.
Oh my god.
They are just like, start.
Please give me what I need.
Give me what I need.
Yes!
Oh that's a sexy hand there.
Come on!
Yeah!
Baby hand!
I bet Mint also passed Snake in a jar.
And I'll have a reward for you.
Ok.
I'm ready.
Come on!
Give me what I need.
Yeah!
Oh that was one!
Oh my gosh.
I thought that one was already done.
Like already clicked on.
Yeah!
20 seconds!
Deny it?
Oh.
No, but I do have Snake in a jar.
Game?
I think my game crashed.
No!
It was like... It said... It said your best is too fast.
There is no way you are a child.
This game is only for children.
No way.
No!
Hold on.
Let me click out of it.
Oh here maybe.
Ok.
Hold on.
Ok, I'm leaving.
Let's try this.
I'm gonna leave.
We'll come back to that later.
Oh no!
As soon as I do anything...
Ok, let me try restarting the game.
Do you want to stop playing?
Yes.
Ok, let's try again.
Hopefully it's saved.
Oh no!
Anti-cheat maybe.
Alright Big Fish.
I might demand a refund if this doesn't work for me please.
I'm Mickey!
You've come back again.
There is really no doubt that you want to keep going and find your way out.
It's true!
Ok, let's see if it kept all our stuff.
Ok!
Ok.
Maybe we are fine.
Maybe we are ok.
Let's go to this room first.
Look!
We can go to his room.
I spy a stamp.
The second floor.
An open window.
Second floor.
The second floor.
A stamp.
An open window.
Not anymore.
A desk drawer.
A broken clock.
My ears!
Three birds.
Three...
Don't tell me...
That's a penguin.
I mean I guess it's...
I guess?
Does that count?
It's a bird?
Does that really count though?
A penguin is a bird.
It doesn't count.
A feather pen.
Get out!
Oh my god!
He's cursing us!
Cheese in a trap.
Oh my gosh!
Do you see this ghost right here?
That's such a good one!
Guys, a ten.
We need a ten and we need...
Two more birds.
Oh here's a bird.
Oh I see the ten!
One more bird.
What if it was a middle finger?
Oh here!
Is the ten at the bottom right?
No it's not.
Three birds.
That one was tricky.
Easy.
Game.
Oh wait, they didn't...
Ok, for some reason I thought they rhymed great or eight with eight.
No.
Ok, great with eight.
Ok, I get it.
Yeah, ok.
A bell!
Bing bong.
He's pointing at me again.
Two nails.
One nail.
Single nail.
A Y.
Y, Y, Y, Y, Y.
Skeet on study.
What does that mean though?
What does that mean?
A spider.
A fly, a fly, a fly, a fly.
Fly.
A fly.
It's a skeleton?
No it's not.
Ske...
Arrow
that points to the skeleton's study.
A green boot that's muddy.
How to haunt.
An open book.
I probably wrote that one just like that other book.
I'm a published author after all.
A dinosaur tail?
Oh here.
How cute!
A dinosaur tail.
I see the second nail.
Skeet on study.
Two nails.
Skeet on study everybody!
Everybody!
What is that?
Skeet on study.
Okay we gotta do this one now.
This one's fun.
Scream!
A skull.
Skeet on study.
That's what Corey would have done.
I hope Corey is okay.
A three.
A fly.
He's behind my head.
Nasty fella.
A fly.
A frown.
Does this count as a frown?
Looks like my uncle.
A leafless tree.
A broken wing.
That's so sad.
They make it sound so happy though.
Let's see.
A yellow beak.
That's not yellow.
Oh here!
A yellow beak.
And a butterfly eek.
I saw the eek before.
Oh here.
A butterfly eek.
Now we just need an iron gate.
Iron gate.
Oh wait!
Oh it's in all caps.
So it's this place.
Iron gate.
Yay!
Eyeballs!
Okay, finish this room.
Nice We'll save that one for last.
Possibly.
I'm terrified.
Go in here now.
One pencil is behind me.
Another pencil is...
here.
Are you sure you didn't voice this game?
Does it really sound like pencils?
Two pencils.
A hand!
A hand.
Let me give you a hand.
A little bit.
If you try...
Three doors.
One?
Oh my god.
One door.
One door?
Two doors?
Oh my gosh!
That's so good!
Because the mirror spun around last time and then it contributes to...
The third door.
And it contributes to the puzzle this time.
That's so fun.
A bug on the wall.
A name that is yours!
What's it going to sound like?
A name that is yours.
A comb.
A six.
And this one was a nine before.
Now it's a six.
A six?
Ouch.
A rose.
A single red rose.
A little bathtub.
Does this count as little?
Oh my god.
A little bathtub.
I guess so.
And a wallpaper nose.
This is so cute.
Like there is a snail here.
A wallpaper nose.
What is that?
Eleventh.
Guys are killing it.
We are definitely speedrunning here.
Alright, let's go into the closet.
Oh the creepy dolls.
Everything is staring at me.
Cool.
You guys got lucky because it was hidden by chat.
I mean it was my birthday today.
Castillo!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Castillo.
Happy birthday!
A jack.
Oh this thing.
Two horns.
One horn?
I see the second one.
It's pretty tricky.
Dark seed.
Two horns.
Voice acting.
What does that mean?
Eyeglasses.
Oh sorry.
Actually I had to click.
There is a bear behind me.
You guys can't really see but it's funny because I'm also wearing glasses today.
I'm awesome.
A nose that is blue.
Three cats in a row.
So cute!
I remember playing the pirate version of I Spy.
I prefer that over the...
Ok, well nobody asked you.
Ok, I like this one better.
That's your opinion.
If you like the pirate one, go play that one then.
This is the only one I played.
What is that?
That sounds like a weenie whisper right there you guys.
They are like this game is too scary.
Other versions of Dark Seed don't have voice acting.
I see, I see.
I'll look into it.
Everyone is a critic.
So true.
A top hat.
Everyone is a critic man.
A top.
And a fly on a head.
That's more like a face.
I mean it's technically the head but...
Oh no!
Get off the cat!
Awful!
When you ask for a hint, I wonder how big of a hint it gives you, you know?
Like does it tell you exactly?
Let's try it next time.
Soup!
Wait, if we are making shrinking soup...
There is one... Do I have to play this a third time?
Because there is one ending I remember distinctly.
And you don't... Wait, maybe you don't.
I don't know.
I see the crow.
And me.
This is my...
Guys, this is my author debut.
A tail.
Croaky.
Three stars in a row.
Wait, we already did the moon.
Oh it's in all caps.
Moon.
A light switch.
We are speedrunning this for real.
Kind of.
Well, sometimes.
Oh here.
Oh no!
Turn it off!
No!
This poor guy, he's trying to sleep.
My name!
One bell?
Welcome to membership Omni!
Thank you!
An open pin.
This is so rude.
Why did we do this to poor little mouse?
So sad.
Two nines.
According to the AI you are playing Weenie Wisp Jr.
Three nines.
Nice.
A nail.
A nail, nail, nail.
And a bunny tucked in.
There it is!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Cheese!
Two!
Boobs!
Alright.
Do we attempt this again?
Do you think it's fine?
OK, it saved us.
I think we are OK now guys.
Oopsie.
My bad.
What?
What happened?
Oh my God!
Why do I keep clicking on the butterflies?
I'm thinking of butterflies this time.
For some reason.
I'm scared of this one though.
I just want to get out of it.
I don't want to do it anymore.
So bye.
Me throwing glasses is dangerously cute.
Bug juice.
Yippee!
Yay!
OK, get me out of this.
No.
No, no, no, no.
I don't want to.
Get me out of here.
I'm scared.
No.
Let me out.
My game is going to freeze.
OK.
Two hangers.
One hanger.
Tails of a cat.
The tail of a cat.
A face in a frame.
Is this count?
Is that the face in a frame?
A face in a frame.
A dusty top hat.
We got to find the other hanger.
Oh!
Two hangers.
Dusty top hat.
Here!
A dusty top hat.
I see the necklace.
So good.
You guys, we got this.
We got this.
We are speed running.
Speed run.
You can't see the cat over there though.
Tip of a ski.
I don't think you should be doing that.
Single earring.
Oh I saw it.
There.
A single earring.
Do you guys see the sock?
Sniff it out.
A loop in a string.
And a sock.
Sniff the sock out everybody.
Sniff it out.
Sniff, sniff, sniff, sniff.
Smell the sock.
Smell for it.
I found it.
A sock.
Please Minky, I'm not that freaky.
You will become that freaky though.
Here's the last ingredient.
Take a good look.
Then go to the kitchen.
You are ready to cook.
We are ready to cook baby.
Oh my gosh.
We are cooking.
I wonder if there is one more exit.
Or one more time you have to play the game to get all the endings.
Oh, to the kitchen.
That's right.
Let's cook.
You found everything you need to make Shrinking Soup.
Look at all the bug spices.
Into the pot, six ingredients will go.
First pour in four eyes, stacked in a row.
Ok, I got it.
Wait, only six?
Then why did I get all this stuff?
Mr. Carrier, thanks for two months.
I'm rude and old.
Welcome to Mavish.
Thank you.
Spicy.
Look to the left of the pickled snake.
Take that red bottle and give it a shake.
What the hell?
Now you must measure precisely.
A one pound egg will do nicely.
One pound egg?
What?
How huge is this egg?
I'm sorry, what?
It's one pound?
Oh, it's green.
Did they just throw the...
To give this soup shrinking power, sprinkle in a bit of flour.
Flour.
Oh, is this flour?
Ew.
Green eggs and ham?
I do not like them Sam-I-Am.
Before the soup gets too cold, add a pinch of something old.
Ok guys, I'll make the sacrifice.
Put me in coach.
Put me in.
I think it's this.
Oh it's actually mold.
Ew, it was so gross.
Why did we get the cheese and stuff?
A bit of bug spice and the soup is complete.
Add some caterpillar, nice and sweet.
Caterpillar.
But Matara isn't here yet.
Get the largest spoon to stir the soup.
Let it boil, then take a full scoop.
We have to eat this?
What was the point of the frog legs and everything then?
Here we go.
Oh my gosh.
Time to eat everybody.
Now go find a door that's fit for a mouse.
Then eat this shrinking soup to get out of the house.
There's no door fit for a mouse here.
I made the soup delicious for you now everybody.
So it was right here, right?
At the very beginning.
Here we go!
You've escaped my house again.
Do you dare to come back in?
There's still something you've never seen.
The plans to fix my ghost machine.
Ghost machine?
There's so much replayability in this.
You know this door is tightly sealed.
A new way out must be revealed.
The plans you need you'll find downstairs by my ghost machine that needs repairs.
So this one?
Here are the plans to fix my ghost machine.
Solve I-Spy riddles and play games to earn the missing parts.
One more time!
Oh my God.
We have to assemble.
Alright guys, I think this is the last one though.
Alright, let's do this.
What is this one?
Oh chalk.
What is this?
A nut cracker.
Lock.
Tennis.
Baseball.
Golf.
What is that?
Oh it's tooth.
We got it.
Finally finished watching all your ghost babble.
It's 2AM.
Oh, goodnight Chad!
Thanks for watching!
Alright, alright.
How do they match?
Oh no.
No.
Wait, what?
Oh they rhyme!
So tie with I...
Wait.
Hole?
Dice?
Die with...
Hole.
Skate with eight.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Star with...
Is there a jar?
No.
Star with...
What?
Dice with mice.
Oh!
I was thinking rat.
Oh my gosh.
OK.
Dice, mice.
We are just going to go for it.
Eight, skate.
Four door.
Snail, nail.
What was this one?
Spoon, moon.
Sun, one.
Star, car.
Book, hook.
Chair, bear.
Bat, cat.
Key, tree.
One more.
Oh no, this was...
Four.
Where is it?
What the hell?
Oh my god, it's not even just numbers sometimes.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, this is so tricky.
What?
No way!
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6...
Wait, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
Oh my gosh.
6, but it's also...
6, oh my gosh.
4, there it is.
6, wait.
2, 2.
5, 5.
3, 3.
1.
Oh my gosh, how many are here?
Probably 12, yeah.
10.
We are so good at this.
It's 47.
My best was 18.
You know what, not bad.
You are the cutest ghost girl alive.
Fight me bro.
Randevis, I'm dead.
I'm not alive.
I'm not... I'm dead.
I'm a ghost.
I spy three pins, a loose thread, a striped...
Three pins.
A pumpkin.
A horseshoe.
OK guys, speed run.
Shovel.
Shovel 1.
Shovel 2.
One shovel.
We are speed running.
Two shovels.
A ball.
A ball?
Oh.
Your ghost form is alive.
Your human form is long...well I guess that's true.
B!
Pin in the top left.
Thank you!
One pin.
Two pins.
Is this a...Oh this is a closed pin so it counts.
Also loose thread.
A loose thread.
We just...Raccoon!
Oh my god!
Snuffy!
A striped raccoon.
What's a pumpkin head?
That's me!
Oh my god!
A pumpkin head.
A heart.
The tree is pin.
No, it doesn't count.
Good thinking though.
I think that's a nail.
They don't really count it as a pin.
And a fish.
A fish.
Fish.
Heart?
That's right!
I even pointed it out before.
I was like oh look at the heart.
A bird in a tree.
A fish.
We need one more pin and a fish.
How are you a pumpkin?
You are green.
What are you talking about?
Fish on top of the tree?
Oh, you're right!
A fish.
And three pins.
One more pin.
The bowling pin!
Three pins.
Yeah!
Good job guys!
Strike!
We got a metal gear.
Here's machine part two.
I'll put it down in the workshop for you.
One more.
In here.
I spy three snakes.
A nail on the ground.
A dime.
Nail on the ground.
Oh my gosh!
That's the nail we made fall earlier.
A nail on the ground.
Oh my gosh.
Three snakes.
Solid.
One snake.
Liquid.
Two snakes.
Solidus.
It's behind me.
Sorry.
Right of us.
Welcome to my workshop.
Thank you.
In here.
Thank you for the five gifts.
Three snakes.
A dime.
A diamond.
Diamond.
Oh like a diamond shape.
Probably.
That's a heart shape.
Diamond shape.
A frame that's round.
A lantern.
Do you guys see a diamond?
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
The picture frame diamond.
Yeah!
I just saw it.
Oh my gosh.
A cat.
A queen.
Four letters.
One letter.
Two letters.
Three letters.
They don't...wait, they do spell something.
Fire.
Nice.
Good job guys.
Good job.
Four letters.
Who needs observation duty when we have this game, right?
Tamanaki!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Two holes for eyes.
And the number 13.
Spooky.
The number 13.
Thank you.
Check my plans and you'll see where to put machine part three.
The rhymes are too long.
They are too cute.
Alright, we are done with this room.
On to this.
Minky!
One spider.
Stop talking!
Stop making that noise!
So loud.
A red K.
Minky!
I thought that said number four.
Oh yeah, sorry that I'm covering...I wish I could move, but unfortunately I can't.
With how today is set up.
So I'm really sorry.
A shadowy X.
Minky!
I will say that you think that my mama's art is cute.
Which of course, Ayami mama's art is the cutest!
An upside down key.
Three hearts.
One here.
One heart.
Two hearts.
One more heart.
Two keys on a chain.
A key back in place.
An ace.
A three.
I only got the one spider.
I can't find the other spider.
Spitter, spitter!
I see a bee.
I see a frog.
Spitter...oh here I see him!
Guys!
Oh my God!
Horrible!
Horrible, horrible sounds.
Two spiders.
Don't laugh at that.
Oh I see another heart.
Nice.
That one hurt bad.
Three hearts.
An acorn?
I saw it earlier.
Oh my gosh where did it go?
And then a plane.
A plane and an acorn guys.
Acorn!
An acorn.
Now a plane.
Did you guys see a plane?
Astro cat!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Below the king.
Oh no that's an acorn.
On the postcard.
Oh good find!
Good find!
A plane.
Good job guys.
Puntor!
Thanks for 5 months!
That one was really small.
Good find guys.
That's a lot.
11 more is a whole ton.
I guess we can do stuff in the kitchen again, huh?
Three cups.
Oh wow now we have all the ingredients and stuff.
A cat that's gold.
Yeah I found them!
Mold.
This is a chill stream game.
It is, right?
Having fun.
I hope you guys are chill.
Oh my god.
Sometimes I can't.
I think that's a cup.
That's one cup.
The first bug in the line is a snail.
Oh here!
Ewww.
Blue snail spice.
That was a real chill.
Does this count as a cup or is this a jar?
Wow look at him go!
A snake.
Nevermind.
Bug twice.
Bug once.
And now bug remover.
What's the other cup?
Oh there are two more cups right here.
I'm so silly.
Nice.
Okay.
Two cups.
One cup.
One more cup.
Three cups.
Alright we got an empty bottle right up here behind you guys.
And then a candle.
Candle, candle, candle.
A candle?
Do you guys see a candle?
Say I if you see a say.
Say, say, say, say.
Say say if you see a candle.
Oh I see it!
You don't see it because it's behind me.
You guys said say but you couldn't see it.
It was literally behind my head.
You guys are liars all of you.
Rob, Otamegin, King, Resting Glitch Face, Nyko, David...oh my god terrible sound.
Brian, you all said say and I'm calling you out.
You guys are lying.
You guys lied.
Not Brian.
I know right?
One coin.
Two coins.
I mistook you for a candle because of how you light up my life.
Negative two!
I like how it split.
Plus two, negative two.
That was pretty smooth though.
That was a good one.
A sailing ship.
Sailing ship.
Sailing, sailing on the ocean blue.
Oh here it is.
Sorry it was behind my head.
Oh my god the ship just went down!
Nevermind it's fine.
A heart.
Heart, heart, heart, heart, hearty heart, heart.
Hearty heart, heart, hearty heart.
Does Nero-sama still do that?
Hearty heart, heart?
That was one of my favorite things she would do.
Hearty heart, heart, hearty heart.
The horse!
She does?
Sometimes.
A paperclip.
Not much anymore.
An open mouth.
Open mouth.
Open mouth?
I don't even see... no his mouth is closed.
I don't see one at all.
The mouth is hard.
Do you see it?
Open mouth.
Up, up, up, up.
What's the other ones?
An S?
S, S, S.
Oh here.
An S.
A fly in a cup?
I see a couple of flies, but not one in a cup.
There is not even a cup.
Oh here.
That's a cup.
A fly in a cup.
Maybe the saw?
This one?
An open mouth.
Oh my god!
What?
That's...
That's... OK.
OK game.
I see the needle.
And a spotted beetle.
It does kind of look like a troll face.
I am.
That's why I'm wearing glasses today.
I'm so smart.
Yes.
That's why I have my glasses on you guys.
So we are so smart.
Oh sorry I accidentally clicked out of it.
A hammer!
Two nuts?
Is this a nut?
One nut.
Sorry.
I shouldn't laugh at...
Oh this one I think is behind me.
It's metal...well it's gears, but I think it counts.
Nope, nevermind.
It doesn't count.
I thought it was like nuts and...oh is this a nut?
Two nuts.
I was thinking of like nuts and bolts.
That's what the gears...OK a shell.
A shell, a shell, a shell, a shell.
Also, a cobwebby name!
Give me my Zen Zen Zen.
Oh here is the shell.
Big shell?
A shell.
Metal gear.
A flower.
Hold on let me check my...let me check something real quick.
OK I'm good.
A bell.
A bell, a bell, a bell, a bell, a bell, a bell, a bell, a bell, a bell, a bell, a bell, a bell, a bell, a bell.
It's a bell.
It was behind my head, sorry.
I see the pin.
You do?
Seven in place.
We got to put this in place.
Nice.
We got to move this for midnight.
Time.
Bing bong bing bong.
A carved violin.
Here.
And a pin.
Oh I see it!
I see it.
Good job guys, good job.
Oh I forgot to try the hint.
I want to see what happens if it like gives you...
Like a straight up hint or if it's like...
Or if it's like just tells you where it is you know.
I'm curious.
Alright.
Did we complete downstairs then?
I think so.
We can go upstairs.
I can tell.
Let's do the secret room.
Eyes by a chimney.
A chimney.
Out a chimney.
Chimney, chimney, chimney.
A chimney.
Oh yeah, let's try the hint.
Alright.
Subsea.
Did you notice the items around the clock all rhyme with the numbers they're next to?
Love this game, so much nostalgia.
Oh yeah, I didn't notice that.
What?
That's so good.
The ghost fart.
Don't call it that.
Out.
Get out.
A chain.
A chain, a chain, a chain.
This is the room we know the least since we've only been in here like one time.
Oh that's a recorder.
That's crazy.
A question mark.
A chain.
A ghostly face?
A ghostly face.
A snake and a plane.
Oh my god, snakes on a plane?
I see an arrow.
Eyeglasses.
Ghost fart glass.
Don't call it that.
Oh, on the ceiling fan.
Thank you.
A chain.
Nice, good find.
A plane.
And a snake.
An ink in a jar.
Ink in a jar.
A star.
Two moons.
One moon?
One moon.
This is not the snake.
This is a lizard, right?
Two moons.
We need a question mark.
Oh yeah, are you here?
Nice.
A question mark.
Is it a paper plane?
Smarty pants on my ears.
I see the snake.
Snake on wallpaper.
Yeah!
And four arrows.
We have one.
Two arrows.
Three arrows.
I believe this is our fourth.
Good job guys!
Oh my god!
The hint is like...
Yay!
I'm ready to make ghosts.
We can't wait.
Are we killing people?
Wait.
Wait a second.
Skelly man, what do you mean by that?
Eyes by five ears.
A yo-yo.
Five ears?
Open mouth.
An open mouth.
A yo-yo.
We saw the yo-yo before.
Where is the yo-yo now?
Yo-yo.
A yo-yo.
Oh here.
Time to be evil.
We are making ghosts.
A sun.
Skeet on study.
And one ear.
Do you think these count as two ears?
I think so.
Three ears.
This guy's ear.
Four ears.
And then this little rat's ear.
Nice five ears.
Five ears.
Oh this way there is the apostrophe.
A skeleton study.
No.
Skeeton study.
Number one.
We got seven, four.
Bats, bugs, windows, doors, plumbing is behind me.
Six five letter words.
Ok, doors is one.
Ghost is a five letter word.
Man I love these.
Thanks for the nostalgia Minta.
Of course!
Three!
Haunt is a five letter word.
Oh the trophy has one.
Good job.
Soups?
How many are we at?
Five.
Five letter words.
Ok we need one more.
Is it study?
Have you read How to Haunt Minto?
I wrote that.
I wrote the whole book on that.
On how to haunt.
Oh that's so cute.
A match.
I saw this before I think.
Or was it a different one?
Oh no I did.
I saw this tiny little match there.
Oh my god don't set the rat on fire!
A match.
The longest green tail.
That is a pretty long tail.
And three little birds.
So we got one bird here.
We got a little bird here.
Two little birds.
Oh and an owl.
An owl, an owl.
Three little birds.
Such a lust for revenge.
Seven!
One of my favorite things to quote from Seinfeld.
Seven.
Did you guys ever watch Seinfeld?
I watched it somewhat recently.
So I quote mostly that.
Basically...
George Costanza is trying to figure out the name.
The perfect baby name.
And he comes up with...
Seven.
Is it like Friends?
I never watched Friends.
Friends.
Is Friends any good?
Let's do this one.
Red Rose.
This one.
A moon.
Oh my god the moon is tiny.
It's like Friends but funny.
No soup for you!
I like that one too.
Fright?
Fright.
Where is fright written?
Fright?
I don't see a fright.
Oh, a fright.
Why?
It's an all cap so it should be written right?
Like one of these words.
I always consider Lucky Star to be a Seinfeld anime.
Yeah?
Maybe, yeah.
A fingerprint.
Oh my gosh.
A fish?
Wait, I don't see any of these things.
OK, we gotta lock in you guys.
We gotta lock in.
Oh wait, there is a fish.
A fish.
My favorite was these pretzels are making me thirsty.
I don't remember that one.
I feel like maybe Azumanga is more like Seinfeld.
No, maybe...
I don't know.
Serenity now!
Oh my gosh, there is so much good stuff to quote from Seinfeld.
So good.
The eye of a needle.
The tongue of a snake.
Where is a snake at?
This looks like a car.
Are these things even...
What?
That's an owl.
Three eights in a row?
We can find this one.
Oh, here we go.
Three eights in a row.
Guys, this one is tricky.
In the boot?
What boot?
Boot?
A paper snowflake.
Oh, I see this one.
I saw that one earlier.
OK, a fingerprint.
Fingerprint.
Red moth, maybe tongue.
I think that...
I don't see a snake here though.
I see fright, you do?
I see scream.
I see eek.
Whatever that says.
This one is maybe the one that stumped me the most.
And the eye of a needle.
Middle...Oh my gosh!
Yeah, middle, bottom.
Oh my god.
The tongue of a snake.
Would you ever play the other Eye Spy games?
Maybe, if you guys want me to.
I've never played those before though.
I don't even see a needle in here.
I have a needle.
I see nails.
Oh here it is!
Oh my gosh!
You guys see this?
The needle was the second half.
Oh my god!
That's crazy!
What?
OK, a fingerprint.
A fingerprint.
That one was super duper sneaky.
Especially without the magnifying glass.
That was so good.
A fright and a fingerprint.
Does this count as a fingerprint?
No.
Fright is top left.
Oh but...
What?
Oh my gosh!
Wow!
OK, nice!
Nice!
You guys have good vision.
Wow!
Now a fingerprint.
Fingerprint.
I'm looking at the bodies.
I'm looking at...
All around fingerprint.
Bottom looks like a place to hide the fingerprint.
I don't think it's like that.
No, I don't think that's a fingerprint.
Any fingerprints on here?
I can't believe it didn't say the owl face.
Top right left wing.
Top right left wing?
No, that's a feather.
Fingerprint.
I don't want to use the hint.
I'm looking around.
It's not in the spider web.
Let's scram.
Bottom middle butterfly below the left wing.
This?
You have to be...
Oh my gosh, you have to be hovered over it.
Wow!
A fingerprint.
That's really clever.
Wow!
That was super duper subtle.
By now you know my little scheme.
Here's the tenth part of the ghost machine.
Tenth part.
Nice.
Good job guys.
Thank you for the help on that one.
That was super duper well hidden, right?
This kid's game still can get us a little bit sometimes.
Which I appreciate.
Mickey!
A bear?
Oh my god!
Calm down!
Holy shit!
Oh my god.
If that didn't wake anybody up, I don't know.
Good morning Minto!
Jeez!
Chill guy!
Two ducks.
A snail.
Oh my gosh, I noticed the snail last time.
Minky, Minky.
A vase with three flowers.
A spotted tail, this one.
A spotted tail?
I was playing Stalker and that was a big mistake.
I thought it was a blood sucker.
Sorry to scare you Donnie.
A pair of scissors.
Oh here.
A pair of flies.
A bottle half full, it's behind my head.
A bottle half full.
And yellow eyes.
This one we sped through easy.
Phoenix, thanks for seven months!
I need scissor 61, I need scissor 61.
Lightning fast.
That one was super duper easy.
Not yet, but we'll get there.
Let's do this room.
Three horses.
One horse.
There is a chess horse piece behind me.
Stop it!
Stop these sounds, they are terrible.
Please spare my ears.
A third horse.
Oh here, a tiny.
Sheepy, thanks for five months!
English, thanks for seven months.
I spy one cute ghost.
A button nose.
A mirror.
A brush.
A brush, a brush.
A brush with death.
Actually, where is the brush?
Where is the brush?
A brush.
Brush!
And a bat.
I see the bat.
Oh my god.
A bat.
Oh my gosh, I probably would have missed that.
White toes?
Oh like a paintbrush.
Is there a paintbrush?
Paintbrush?
I'm looking for a paintbrush.
Oh I see it!
Nice!
I dream about cheese.
Me too sometimes.
Welcome to Mambo Shop!
A cat's tail.
Yeah, get that...
I thought you were going to get that nasty fly off your face.
Is this a vest?
No, it's a coat.
A green vest.
Why does everything need to be oiled so badly?
Four red shoes.
One red shoe.
Two red shoes.
Four red shoes.
I mean three red shoes.
Because it's spookier that way.
I guess it is an old mansion.
You're right.
Except the bathroom.
The bathroom is exceptionally clean, but they just never touch the closet.
The biggest ears?
Do you think it's the dogs or do you think it's the rabbits?
Who has bigger ears?
Peace of dog!
Welcome to Mambo Shop!
And David, welcome to Mambo Shop!
The dog.
And two twos.
That's a three.
Oh two?
Oh my god, that one is kind of sneaky.
Oh my gosh and I found the other one.
Nice!
Grimble!
Thanks for five months!
Two twos.
We did it!
I'm excited.
I really can't wait to summon the ghost.
One plus one plus one is three.
That's how many more parts you'll get from me.
I can't wait to summon the ghost.
Summoning a ghost.
It's kind of sad that the thing, like the little paper, covers up so much of the screen.
You have all this stuff going on down here too.
You would never know it.
Last thing in this room baby.
Eight stars!
Holy shit!
OK there is one.
Two.
Three.
Three stars.
Four.
Four stars.
Five.
Five stars.
Six.
Six stars.
Seven.
Seven stars.
And eight.
Yeah!
Eight stars.
That one is time consuming.
Yeah guys, I'm a published author, Minky.
That's me.
Yeah, you might be wondering, you might be wondering like, wow.
What does she do with all that amazing royalties and things like that?
It's hard to say.
Everywhere I go people are like, are you the one that wrote that Yuri book?
And I'm like, stop it.
Stop it.
I just say I bought an old haunted mansion and I only used the bathroom in there.
That's it.
A toy doll.
Where?
Also a closed eye.
One closed eye.
Two closed eyes.
And then this little mouse.
Go back to sleep little mouse.
Three closed eyes.
A crayon.
Thanks for one more month.
Thank you.
Thank you Nero.
How about a reading from your book?
Just a page or so.
I'll read you.
What lovely eyes you have, she said flirtatiously.
Thank you, she said back, flirting her eyes at the girl.
Flirt, flirt, flirt.
I wish to partake in a kiss, said girl.
Oh my gosh, me too, said other girl.
Then they kissed.
And then the moon crashed from the sky and impacted earth.
And everything was destroyed.
And that is what the moon brought.
Destruction upon the world!
Tasukaru!
Thank you, welcome to membership.
ViviCore, thanks for the gift dude.
Let's see, a crown for you King.
A crown.
Where is a toy?
I didn't see one.
Sorry, it's behind me.
A train.
Cowabunga!
A hand that's red.
A moon on a chain.
I would never guess such a cute ghost could be the author behind such beloved literature.
I just had to give my first Super.
Buzz Buzz.
Thank you buddy.
Thank you.
A heart.
Let's see this one.
A letter turned upside down.
And a hand that's red.
The doll's...no, that's the bear, not the skelly.
Which...what is it?
The second hand on the clock.
A hand that's red.
Nice!
Had to think outside of human hands.
I know.
Only two more missing from the ghost machine.
Ghost machine!
Ghost in the machine.
Boobs.
Alright.
Oh my gosh, wait.
It's actually Doobie's hat.
Tascado!
Oh, thanks for 7 months.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's do this one first.
Let's just get it out of the way.
I'm scared.
Oh Aiba.
It's going so fast.
Done, done, done, done, done, done, done, done.
You're so good at saying thanks.
Thanks!
30 seconds, exactly.
Eyeball.
Hand.
Sexy hand.
Oh, sorry.
I got excited over the one hand.
Baby hand.
Hands.
Come on!
Give me what I need.
Hand.
Hands.
Give me what... Oh my gosh, there are still so many left.
Hand.
Give me what I need.
Oh I missed it.
No!
OK guys.
Pray.
You're pretty good.
Thanks poverty Miko.
Thanks for 7 months.
Lame.
Blink.
I can't tell sometimes which ones I've already clicked and which ones I haven't.
I know that it turns red, but sometimes it's hard for me to...
Oh no!
You can't blame me for that one.
I feel like that one, that was so tricky.
That one was put... Oh my goodness.
Come on.
Nice.
Come on!
I can and I will.
No!
Yes we can.
Minky gaming!
Yeah!
One more!
Let's go!
Oh.
Creepy collection.
Minky!
Minky out.
Siege!
Thanks for 7 months.
Alright, last one guys.
I see the bow tie.
Two letter B's.
Letter B.
One red eye.
Four wheels.
One wheel.
This level always scares me as it can.
Me too!
It's so funny.
It's so funny what things scare us when now it's just like...
There is no jump scares in this game, you know?
So it's like...
Like there is no reason to get scared.
Oh a belt.
Thanks for 5 months!
A metal key.
Pencil.
Wooden pin.
I think that counts, yeah.
A wooden pin.
One red eye.
Two letter...we got the one letter B.
I just need one more.
Where are...
Four wheels.
We got two.
A metal key.
Mint pie!
Thank you!
Thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
A wheel!
Oh boo!
Pencils on the...
Pencils on the right?
Where you see it?
Where?
Oh there is the red eye!
Nice.
One red eye.
Pencil.
Thank you guys!
A pencil.
Four wheels.
A wheel.
We got two wheels.
Another wheel.
Three wheels.
We need a three and a whale.
Oh there is a whale!
Where is Waldo's stream deck?
That would be so fun.
I wanna do like the Nancy Drew games too.
Since they are also missing or hidden object games.
I love hidden object games.
But maybe they are not like the most interesting streams.
A three!
Oh my gosh.
A three.
Alright, one more wheel guys!
One more wheel!
Wheel, wheel, wheel.
We got those two.
Is this wheel?
No.
Try the suitcase.
For a wheel?
The cat?
Oh wait!
Oh my gosh.
The second wheel was down there!
I see what you mean.
Oh my gosh.
Good job guys!
And that's our final piece.
Time to start the ghost machine!
Let's go!
There is only one Nancy Drew game I've ever played and it's the one about the...
I'm sorry.
It's the one about the haunted Ryokan.
I'm such a loser!
It's really good though.
Yo, Mito!
Yo, Chaotic Snow!
Follow the plans to put the parts in place.
OK Oh!
Wait, my bad.
Sorry, I thought that would get rid of the...OK.
Follow the plans.
This one goes here.
This goes here.
What else we got?
We got our little S.
Our little S goes here.
A magnet and S goes there.
Magnet goes here.
S goes here.
Oh sorry, S goes here.
I wonder what kind of ghost we are making you guys.
Ever thought about playing Fear?
It could be a hidden object game.
I have played Fear before.
I really liked it.
That drippy thing and that drippy thing.
This.
A star and diamond.
Yeah, see this is a drippy thing.
Funnel.
Yeah.
Yeah, shut up.
Shut up, you guys.
A wind cork.
Wind cork.
This.
Tube.
Ferris wheel.
Dial.
Alright, here you go guys.
The final piece.
I'm going to get summoned.
Ah, the ghost machine is fixed.
Now you can use it to make some very spooky ghosts.
Start by clicking button number 1.
Wait, why can't I?
Oh, start?
What if I pick 4?
Rusty.
To make this ghost, you have to fill these jars by finding ingredients that I've hidden around the house.
No way.
Here's a clue for the first ingredient you have to find.
Go and find 2 crooked nails please.
They're in a cabinet filled with keys.
Cabinet filled with keys?
This one.
Rusty nails.
These ones.
2 crooked nails.
Got them.
A spring is next on your list.
So go look.
It rests on the...
Floor and right next to a book.
Wait, on the floor?
Wait, in here?
Oh no?
Oh wait, I remember where it is.
It's in here.
Here.
I remember.
Alright.
How many things do I need for each ghost?
Fireplace.
Nice!
I got it.
It was behind my body.
How many are there?
This one also was behind me.
Remember the little wheels I said that were in the spiderweb?
I got them.
2 gears.
Rusty!
Rusty, Rusty, Rusty!
Oh my gosh, there is a little switch right behind my head.
I'm sorry, I can't show you.
Go!
It's getting really pixelated.
I have to make all 7 of them?
Holy...
Ok, let's start with number 1 then.
Oh my god.
Shadow.
Me!
Thanks for the 5 gifted.
Ok, I remember seeing this one.
One bat.
Now find a flashlight.
It's in a stair post.
Then you'll be ready to take this...
Nice.
One flashlight to see the ghost.
Let's go back!
Go!
I want to see Shadow the Hedge...Shadow the Ghost...Shadow the Hedge Ghost.
Shadow the...Shadow the Ghost Dog.
No!
Shadow!
He has arms like me!
It gets so pixelated.
Next is...that's not a ghost.
That's a place.
Ok, behind...Curtains, curtains, curtains.
We are speedrunning this guys.
Curtains are where the broken bone is.
Right here.
I got it.
One broken bone.
Oh and right here, right here.
RIP R.I.P
Next to the fire.
Right here!
Nice!
We are releasing all the ghosts!
We are releasing the ghosts!
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh!
Graveyard ghost, go!
Snack!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
It gets real pixelated.
I don't know how it looks like on stream.
Oh my god, this guy is really creepy.
Oh no, his arms broke.
Oh, sorry guy.
That's so sad for him.
I'm the final block.
Tick tock!
An hourglass teeters on the arm of a chair.
Go find it.
At the top of the stairs.
An hourglass.
This one!
We got it.
One hourglass.
His arms broke, it's so sad.
An alarm clock is the next thing you need.
Alarm clock.
Got it!
Nice!
Next!
Give me the next thing!
Come on Skelly!
Shelf with the 7th ghost book.
In here?
They
are haunting the place now!
Has anyone mentioned how eerily similar this narrator and the truth from FMA Brotherhood might be the same person?
Rusty is here!
He's skeeting in the study.
Where is the other ghost then?
I think he's up here.
I'm scared.
Tick tock time!
Go!
Here we go!
Tick tock!
Oh no, it's time!
Go!
What a dumb ghost.
Alright, number 5!
Wind up mouse?
It's near a tall clock.
Tall clock.
Was there one in here?
Oh wait!
Duh!
In here!
Meow!
Piece of cheese!
It's behind my head, sorry.
I wish it was the hot dog.
Cat eyes?
They are in a picture on the wall.
I like how he peeks around the corner.
Oh!
We are stealing this cat's eyes!
Oh my god!
That's so sad!
On a shelf full of dolls.
We are too good at this game guys.
It was also behind me a little bit.
You might have seen it.
Meow, meow, meow!
I want to go make a meow!
Let's make a meow!
Meow!
I can't believe I've gotten 3 and a half hours of content out of this game.
I cannot believe it.
Cute!
Oh my gosh, paws!
Looks just like her.
Alright, number 6.
Wait, but there is a 7th one.
I can't...
Ew!
I...
What about the 7th one?
I can't touch it.
It's somewhere in the library.
The eyeball on top of a book.
Why is Rusty in here but we haven't seen anybody else?
7th one is me.
Oh, I know this one.
The snake under the bed.
I saw him earlier.
He is right here.
The cat!
Cute!
Under a marble sink.
We know that one.
Any ghosts in here?
Besides me?
No?
Go to the trunk and open it.
Looked it up.
The narrator was Amy Birnbaum.
Who didn't do Brotherhood, but has a few anime voices.
Yeah, someone mentioned Pokemon earlier.
Like Ash's brother.
Or, sorry.
Ouch, I just bit my tongue again.
Mei's brother.
Yu-Gi-Oh.
Wow, Yu-Gi-Oh even.
There is a big bug in hiding.
Wait, in the trunk, right?
This is the trunk, right?
Oh, sorry.
It looked like a beetle.
It looked like a beetle so I thought it was something.
Hop to a window.
OK.
Spoiler.
Spoiler, spoiler.
Is there anybody in here?
Graveyard!
Cute!
We are just stealing this whole ass frog.
I want to see...OK, wait.
So we made TickTock.
Let's go look at the clock and see if TickTock is here.
Yeah!
Oh, you are kind of on top of him, but that's OK.
What other ones have we made?
Graveyard?
Rusty?
Yeah, Graveyard is in the Graveyard.
Shadow in the secret room.
Oh, OK.
Let's go check it out.
Shadow.
So cute!
I guess we might have seen him if we did the final ghost, but whatever.
I just wanted to see him anyway.
Alright, go!
Critter!
It's going to be an ugly bug!
It's going to be Matoricon!
Oh my God!
Is it going to eat it?
So gently!
Number 7!
That's so creepy!
Oh!
That's so funny.
Oh my gosh, I remember as a kid being so scared of the way he would say get out.
I would be so scared of that.
I would be like... Wait, do we have to find all the ghosts now?
All the ghosts we summoned.
We summoned these guys just to capture them again and use them for our own gain.
Shadow.
Look out the window.
Oh my God!
We really are just stealing them back.
Wait, I know where all of them are though.
Graveyard.
We are making the ultimate ghost.
Ghost Exodia!
Hurry up!
Tick Tock!
You'll face him on the biggest clock.
Tick Tock.
Find a bell on a book and you'll find Rusty too.
Look upstairs.
He's waiting for you.
Sorry.
I'm sorry that I'm skipping through all the rhymes.
I'm just so excited to get through everything.
I'm impatient in this part.
I'm like... Let's just go.
Let's grab him.
Rusty.
This searching is tough.
Are you tired now?
Oh yeah, let's go find the meow.
Rusty.
No, the cat should be saying meow meow.
I guess that's in the kitchen.
I imagine.
Right?
It's the last one we haven't seen where he stays at.
Oh my gosh!
So cute!
He's just kind of looking in there.
Oh my gosh!
We got them all!
Wait,
are we throwing skeleton into the... We're throwing skeleton into the pot.
Skeleton is our final ingredient.
No way.
Skeleton don't do it!
Don't sacrifice yourself!
Oh my god!
He's going to sacrifice himself.
No skeleton!
Oh my gosh, you see them all in the little thing.
That's so cute.
Alright, skeleton.
You guys, 07s.
07s for skeleton.
No, he's doing it for us.
Skeleton!
Here we go.
Time to get out.
Oh my god!
We're grinding him up.
We're electrifying him.
Oh my god.
He's a skeleton ghost!
This spooky night is ending.
It's almost dawn.
The time has come to say goodbye.
You've mastered this game of spooky.
I spy.
Yay!
Oh he waved.
Sorry, I was covering it.
The end!
Yay!
To us, skeleton will always be a diamond dog.
I won't.
I won't spread your ashes to the solar sea.
Skeleton!
Great game.
That was so fun.
Oh we did it.
We 100%ed.
I spy spooky mansion.
Heaven's divide starts playing.
That was so fun.
I'm gonna... I don't know if the game is just gonna...
I don't know if it's just gonna quit out, so I'm going to do this.
And then I'll just see what happens if it quits or...
Oh yep!
Yep!
It immediately exited and would've showed my screen.
Oh there we go.
Okay.
It immediately showed my desktop.
That's so funny.
Woo!
I called it.
Like there's no... Because I knew there was no menu for this game or anything like that, so I figured it would...
Just kind of blip out of existence.
What is the desktop hiding?
Nothing much.
We got... I spy spooky mansion.
There was one thing that was really funny.
I had a... I had a sticky note open.
That's been open of the whole set list for Phantom Thief Concert.
So that would've been really silly if that had been leaked.
Corey has waken up and stolen the car.
What do you mean woken up?
Can you imagine if that...
I just have it like... I had it like pinned to my desktop, so...
That's actually something.
Yeah, that would've been a wild leak.
I like saw it almost right before I started streaming.
I was like...
I need to get rid of that.
I would've probably actually cried.
No, I mean like... I think leaking a set list isn't... Well, not leaking, but like...
I think telling people part of a set list isn't always a bad thing because...
Especially for like...
For, you know, I guess...
For like in our case, neither of us have an original song.
So, for artists where it's like... Oh, it's all the artists' own original songs.
You know what songs that they might play and you know like...
Oh, I'm gonna do... I know how to do like mixes and stuff to these...
To the, you know, artists' original songs.
But like, for us, like... I mean, the set list is like absolutely wild.
You guys are not... You guys are not prepared at all, but...
But...
For this, I almost wanna tell some songs just so people can learn mixes for some of them, you know?
Can you show us your desktop now in a controlled environment, so to say?
I can show you... What am I gonna show you?
There's nothing on it.
I have like... I have really nothing on it.
It's nothing interesting, actually.
I'm looking.
I'm like seriously like there's nothing here.
There's seri... Oh!
There's seriously nothing here.
Let's go to my cafe.
It's been a minute since we've been there.
La la la la la.
La la la.
You went back inside.
You made him sacrifice, boss.
No!
It's on me!
Hold on.
I want my arms.
Okay.
And... Music.
Music, music, music.
Oh my gosh, I can fix my desktop.
I can fix everything now.
Oh, my windows.
Music, music, music.
It's so quiet.
So quiet.
3D debut still on there?
Why not?
I did have that.
Murph!
Thanks for 7 months!
I did have a 3D... 3.0... Not 3D.
Not yet.
Soon.
Hopefully.
One day.
MGSCon mid-roll advertisement.
Oh, maybe we should put that, right?
Oh my gosh, this game completely broke my... The UI on my computer.
Like... Everything's all messy.
I was going to play Space Marine 2, but this evening was... Watching you wiggle to these goofy sounds in glasses was too cute.
Thanks, Liquid Toast!
Okay, so thanks for the 5 gifted!
Guys, I'm still trying to finish my schedule for the week, but I'm not sure what to do on Saturday.
I can show you what I have right now, but I'm still not sure what to do for Saturday.
Hold on.
Uh... Hold on.
Let me export it.
How do I export it?
Oh, here we go.
What's... 11.25.
Let's see.
Schedules.
So this is what I have.
So it can't be something super duper long, because I'm doing a double stream that day.
Tomorrow... I was going to play Holocure tonight, because I've been really wanting to play, but I've been too busy.
So I'm like, the only way I can play Holocure is if it's on stream.
Wednesday, I'm not sure if I'm going to be streaming, because Matara will be coming in.
So, it's really depending on what we're doing.
Like, we might go out for dinner or something like that, you know.
Thursday, no stream.
Sorry.
Thanksgiving.
And Matara is coming for Thanksgiving.
And then Friday, off collab with Matawa.
And then Saturday, I have stream and then Patreon stream.
The evening.
But I'm not sure what to do on Saturday.
Why is there an apology on Friday?
Because I'm subjecting you to MataraCon on my channel.
Basically.
Dates are wrong?
Oh, that's because it's not finished.
That's because I haven't finished it.
Matara.
I usually change the dates at the very end.
Here, I'll do it now, just because you brought it up.
27.
28.
Oh, wait.
Oh, 27, 28.
29.
Wait a second.
Wait.
Oh, 29 is here.
We're skipping 28.
I was like, wait a second, this goes to December 1st.
30 and then 01.
Okay, there we go.
Yeah, I'm not sure what to do.
My friendly neighborhood.
It's Sesame Street meets Resident Evil.
Oh, I've heard of that before.
I think I would want to do that in one go though.
That's from like last year or the year before, right?
Maybe we can start DMC3.
But I would want to stream that for longer, I think.
I think I would want to stream it for longer.
That's where my dilemma comes.
Because I'm like, hmm, something that I can stream for just a little bit.
You know?
I'll figure out something.
More Holocure.
Is it okay?
We can do the maid gun game.
I was gonna do that the week after this.
Since I had maid cafe on Electric Street this week.
Hot dog.
Hot dog!
I have a question about the concert.
Will you and Doki be able to use your 3D models afterwards?
Will you both have 3D debut streams sometimes in the future?
Sorry if you can't say right now.
No, that's a good question.
I can't say for Doki.
For me...
I would like to do a 3D debut stream.
For me, it's a little complicated.
I like the model that I'm getting now.
I think it looks very good.
But I think it might... Because it was kind of rushed...
I feel that it might look great on stage.
But for normal streaming, I'm not entirely sure.
So I actually am commissioning another 3D model.
It's actually in the works.
It's with a team that I originally wanted to go with.
But...
They wouldn't have been able to finish in time for the concert.
Don't get me wrong.
I think the modeler who is making the one for the concert...
It still looks very good.
And I think for it, I will release it so people can make silly videos if they'd like to or whatever.
If you want to put me in Left 4 Dead 2 or stuff like that.
Buy wallet.
It's because I really want you guys to have high quality.
New 3D model.
Thank you.
I...
Had a dream once.
Where I got a 3D model.
And I really didn't like it.
And I felt that compared to other 3D models, it was not good.
It had less detail compared to the other 3D models.
And it made me really sad.
And I wasn't able to use the 3D model for a very long time.
And then I asked them to change it.
And all they did was change the hair color just a tiny bit.
But I had to wait an entire year for that to happen.
And they didn't even make any of the changes that I asked about.
And then I only got to use it like two times.
And then I woke up from the dream.
So I was really frustrated about it.
In the dream.
And I thought...
I want to have a really good proper 3D that I can use.
Yes, yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
So...
Sorry.
But like I said, it's not impossible that I won't use it on stream.
But...
I would like to have a 3D debut.
With a proper one.
Or rather with the second one I'm getting commissioned.
Dreams are crazy.
I know, right?
Thank goodness it was just a dream.
Very specific dream.
I was so angry after that dream.
I wish I could remember my dreams in that much detail.
If I may ask something.
Do you own any other media from Ace Combat franchise?
Something like a game collection or music OST.
I own the soundtrack of Ace Combat 7.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Give your concert model to Kana Uru.
Oh gosh, I'm afraid what he'll do.
Like I said, I'm probably gonna find a way to...
Make it so other people can use it in general.
For, like I said...
Silly videos if anybody would like to make.
As long as you don't fall and show up for anything.
Yeah.
That would be the most replayed part.
That would be so embarrassing.
Don't you own an Ace Combat...
Stick controller?
Oh, I saw one but I didn't buy it.
It might still be available.
He will hurl you into a river.
No, I will throw him into the river.
Me.
Made violence.
So...
But thanks for the question, Berlet.
Mito, have you tried any Sonic games?
Oh yeah, before I went to heaven...
I actually played Sonic.
It's a privated VOD now.
But yeah, I did play Sonic.
Wasn't it hard of them throwing you though?
Yeah, but like, I'm gonna throw him in.
I will not let him win.
I remember your Ace Attorney run too.
Apparently, Ace Attorney...
Before Ghost Babble was my longest stream on my channel.
It was 11 and a half hours.
Because I was finishing the last chapter of...
The last game.
Which Ace Attorney is so...
So much reading.
So...
Yeah.
That's a hell of a game to stream for that long considering it's mostly words.
Right?
It's only words.
Like, I narrated all of Ghost Babble, but...
I don't think I could do it now.
Before, I had a full time haunting, so I was able to...
Do both.
Are my glasses too small?
Hold on.
Or are they too big?
But yeah.
Now, since I...
You know, and at my full time haunting, I didn't really have to use...
I didn't have to talk much.
I just had to sometimes be like...
And sometimes...
Like the occasional moan.
Occasional, like, boo.
Everything like that.
But now I talk all the time on stream, so I don't think I could talk for that long.
You know, I don't think I could narrate for that long.
Like that much narration.
Yeah, occasional moan.
Just ghost things.
Yep, yep, yep.
I know Vtubers already have throat issues, right?
So many Vtubers already have throat problems.
So...
Probably...
Wouldn't be great for me.
Can you teach us how to moan and haunt?
It's like...
But you like...
Moaning is like an instinct.
A ghost instinct, you know?
Right?
Heard of the Luka song...
Wait, you asked this yesterday, didn't you?
Dancer in the Dark by Fatman P?
Yeah, I...
Wait, I answered your question.
Why'd you send another super chat?
I said that I hadn't heard of it, but I'll look into it.
I guess thanks for asking.
Thanks for reminding me.
But you didn't have to send another super chat about it.
It's like it wasn't designed for Ace Combat and mine.
The games are more controller focused.
Just for collection.
I like to collect things.
I like to collect.
Maybe they forgot.
Maybe.
Stop.
Don't.
Drink and super chat.
Hi, VTuber.
As per my previous super chat.
I think, guys, I'm going to...
Head out.
One second.
Dopey just added me.
Or rather, she sent me a request on Discord.
Yippee.
I was previously communicating with her via Twitter DMs.
Which is not ideal.
Don't drink and super chat.
Super chat, then drink.
Have a good rest of your day, Mito.
You guys as well.
Tomorrow we will...
Holocure.
And tomorrow we'll beat stage 4.
I have not been able to beat stage 4 yet, so...
I want to play Holocure so bad, but I've just been too busy.
So...
Sober super.
Thanks, Ashes.
Tomorrow.
It is rough.
I got...
I got to...
The furthest I've gotten is like...
I think it was like...
16 minutes.
Then I died.
Thanks for the fun and silly stream.
Love the glasses.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Yeah.
Have a good night, you guys.
Have a good day, have a good night.
And I'll catch you guys later.
You guys doing okay lately?
I wasn't sure if I went through yesterday.
Oh no!
I'm sorry!
Thanks for the stream, Mito.
Thank you!
Glad you like the glasses.
Nerd.
I'm a nerd.
So are you.
We're all nerds.
Nerds, nerds, nerds, nerds, nerds.
Points at you, nerd.
Points at you, nerd!
See you later!
Bye bye!
Oh, actually...
We haven't done this in a minute.
It's been a minute.
I don't know...
Am I gonna get... Wait.
Let's turn it down a little bit.
Oh yeah!
Thanks for the feed!
Thanks for the fun stream.
I'm glad you guys liked it.
If there's something strange...
Sleeping in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
If there's something weird...
Sleeping in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
Maybe some people... It's been a while since I've done this.
So maybe some people don't know, but...
Before Heaven, I used to end all my streams with Bustin.
If you're seeing things...
Sleeping in your bed.
Invisible man.
Let me tell you something.
So happy I finally got a stream.
Thank you Doodling!
Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin...
Makes me feel good, feel good, feel good...
Freaky Ghost Maid!
Freaky Maid, baby!
I hope you're all alone.
Let me sleep in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
Sleeping makes me feel good.
I'm afraid of no bed.
I try to fit these on my face.
There we go.
Invisible bed.
Freaky Ghost Maid.
They're a little awkward.
Oh gosh, I can't get them to work, you guys.
My face is too 2D.
Makes me feel good.
They're slipping off my head.
Feel good, feel good.
Okay, you know what?
Let's put these like this.
Bustin, Bustin.
Now I look like a sexy librarian.
Makes me feel good, feel good, feel good...
Yeah!
What if I put these here?
Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin...
Makes me feel good, feel good, feel good...
Yeah!
Four eyes!
Bustin, Bustin, Bustin.
Feel good, feel good...
Bustin makes me feel good!
Thank you everybody!
Otsumita!
Bye
bye!
Thank you for the hunkatono.
You thought I wouldn't get it, huh?